establishing a criminal penalty for the
theft of a public servant
we have the prime sponsor representative
love
thank you
yes my bad okay wait I don't have the I
don't even have the bill
representative Cochran I'm sorry no
problem please check my apology chair
and committee thank you for your time
um I'm the sponsor and this is uh my
freshman session and my second bill so
please bear with me if I make any small
mistakes
my name is Travis Corcoran and I'm the
sponsor of this bill
uh the problem in theory New Hampshire
town government is open and fair in
practice while sometimes true but is
also sometimes secretive and biased from
discussions both with constituents and
with multiple lawyers the problem of
town boards that engage in
self-interested governing or casually
violate citizens rights to open
government is a widespread one as a
citizen I've read dozens of New
Hampshire Court cases and rulings
arising out of 10 boards engaging in
conflicts of interest and illegal secret
meetings or Communications this is out
of the hundreds of such cases that exist
and that in turn is a small subset of
the nappend very few citizens Sue when
the rights are violated as lawsuits are
very expensive tedious and stressful
sometimes Town boards do not merely
deliberate an illegal secrecy but
actually purport to make decisions and
authorize expenditures and secrecy
because they know that they act in
secrecy and that their deliberations and
votes will never be made public they're
not constrained by possible
repercussions if an action taken in a
secret meeting is later revealed no one
need admit to voting for it was the
decision made fives of zero four one
three two was there actually a majority
at all was the vote even held there is
no way for anyone but the board members
themselves to know
the current incentives are effectively
heads I win Tails it's a tie
RSA 91a provides the citizens May suit
or illegal of illegally hidden public
information but there's no remedy if a
citizen discovers that actions or
decisions had been made in secrecy there
may be no minutes or votes kept so
merely mandating the release of
non-existent records does nothing
expenditures authorized outside of legal
meetings cannot be clawed back judicial
actions authorized outside of legal
meetings likewise cannot be undone
further the incentives for board members
suffer from the principal agent problem
if they conduct a secret meeting and
authorize expenditures in the very worst
case for the board members a citizen
will sue innocent taxpayers will defend
the behavior that the board took in
court and if the board loses then
innocent taxpayers will pay a second
time paying the plaintiff's legal fees
the pain of misbehavior under current
law lands entirely on the innocent and
those who broke the law suffer zero
consequences
thus the need for this bill a board
member who has a desire to violate the
State Constitution and the law may not
blink at doing so when he knows that he
is entirely immune to personal
repercussions but is much more likely to
take the rights of citizens seriously if
there are possible penalties that would
affect them
the political option is theoretical but
now realistic
in many towns various boards are
appointed Not Elected and so are not
responsive to political process a
concerned citizen who is upset that a
board had you know done such a thing
authorized expenditures uh in an illegal
secret meeting would first need to
propose a warrant article get sufficient
signatures on the petition win uh at the
polls with the warrant radical convert
the town to elected zoning or planning
or whatever other board might be
relevant and then run additional
campaigns to place public-minded
citizens on the boards and even then
harms already committed cannot be undone
and new board members serve under the
same flawed incentives as the old board
members
this bill is complementary to RSA 91a
RSA 91a lets citizens attempt to recover
illegally classified information this
bill provides penalties for actions
taken illegally outside of legal
meetings
finally economy this bill address is a
real problem experienced by the citizens
in towns across New Hampshire is
narrowly targeted and poses no or
minimal costs on towns directly
addressed at the state level
legislation not at a town level via the
political process
the best law is one that causes correct
Behavior by well-tuned incentives this
bill by making board members be aware of
and face some small penalties for
egregious violations of Ethics laws
would improve life for countless New
Hampshire citizens reduce the number of
lawsuits chugged in our overworked
courts and thus reduce costs on the
state and impose minimal or no costs on
the town and that's the end of my
prepared testimony I've submitted this
online but on the drive here I thought
of one illustrative example to explain
uh you know sort of scenario if we have
for example a parent who has a child
with autism or some learning disability
there might be state regulations
mandating that the town provides special
services and of course you know the town
is you know free to not do that in which
case citizens would have to go to the
courts and argue for it and the town
government in turn has to decide whether
it would defend that lawsuit uh they
might you know their two options are
basically the board of Selectmen can
meet and say you know yes we just don't
want to pay for this this parent is
entirely wrong and they are allowed to
do so in closed captioning not available
[Music]
the issue specifically uh is that in
such a case the board might decide to
meet uh and not even call it a meeting
they might meet in a coffee house or
something and say yes this is uh
certainly worth twenty five thousand
dollars from the taxpayers to defend
against this parent trying to
legitimately get the you know uh uh
rights for their children and if the
parents you know then win you know
finally they get the special classes or
the teacher's aid or whatever that state
law mandates
at this point uh the lawsuit is over and
the citizens of the town would like to
know hey we just you know we the town
government uh just violated this parents
rights and then we went to court a
second time to try to insist on that
violation who exactly made this decision
who authorized the expenditure of twenty
five thousand dollars and you know this
is the best case scenario there could be
multiple cases that might get appealed
up to the Supreme Court there might be
following cases so you could end in a
situation where 50 or 75 000 of citizens
uh funds have been spent in you know
sort of Defending these uh lawsuits and
this is exactly why the political
process is open you want to know
retrospectively you know who did this so
that we know whether we should vote for
these people in office a second time and
you also want prospectively the board
members to realize hey the votes that I
take about spending dollars I will be
accountable for it will come out
eventually and under current law
um you know it is wrong to have such a
mating and authorize expenditures but
there is absolutely no way
um for citizens to do anything about it
later that's the inclusion of my
testimony and I'm happy to entertain any
questions
thank you I just have one question if I
may on something that you had just
mentioned and I'm wondering if if I'm
confused or if possibly if I heard what
you were saying incorrectly
you had mentioned uh the example that
you just mentioned what I'm not playing
politics I actually I do work in a
school and I when I work in the special
education department and it sounded me
that the example you were given was a
school
more of a school situation not an actual
local municipality you know we had the
school board right it could bless you
and then of course we have our Board of
Selectmen so was that your intention to
discuss extreme situation would I not
hear correctly that was a good question
uh and thank you for it
um the as I mentioned that was an
example that came to me to sort of uh
concretize it as I was driving and I
didn't get the chance um but you know we
can supplement that with any other
example where uh you know if we wanted
to make it a zoning issue where a uh
zoning board of appeals
authorizes uh you know a body shop in a
residential area
um and then the citizen you know wishes
to appeal that goes to court and the
board of Selectmen for example in the
scenario might have a secret meeting
um and so you know the citizen in the
end might win say yes that was an
illegal zoning decision it was made
improperly and we say you know this was
such a slam dunk the BOS you know made a
really silly decision to all authorized
expenditure of twenty thousand dollars
who exactly did that so that I can keep
that in mind when I go to the polls
thank you I like that example much
better are there any questions from
anybody in the committee
representative Muse
I notice in the bill
um you uh there's a liberal use of the
word theft
um I'm sorry I can't quite hear you
sorry about that in the in in the bill
in the wording of the bill itself you
use the word theft pretty liberally
um and in in New Hampshire's theft
typically has a criminal penalty this
bill has uh civil penalties
um curious about your your use of the
wording and and why it appears in here
um so again I missed the one critical
word because a door was opening um but I
think I can answer it even having missed
the word
um this was uh drafted by OLS um and uh
it depended on their help I would
absolutely be amenable to changing the
wording to uh make it in keeping uh with
the intent
thank you
representative selig
thank you I'm I'm sorry that I I
apologize that I'm going to phrase this
awkwardly I'm still trying to formulate
how to make this make sense so if I
understand this correctly if
um for example
Joe the plumber
um goes to the planning board and asks
them to create a legal zone for him
within his district to rezone his house
so that he can have his Plumbing trucks
all be parked there uh where it would
not otherwise be and they approve it and
then his next door neighbor
um goes to the you know go sues the
planning board for approving that
decision
um
and the planning board then hires an
attorney to defend their decision
is it is it your premise that that's
theft that they're I'm just trying to
make sense of I I think I understand the
question I can speak to it
um so so that was excellent that's a
perfect example uh currently it is uh
absolutely illegal and in in under this
bill would absolutely continue to be
legal that the uh Board of Selectmen
would authorize
um a defense of that and win or lose
that's fine and that would not be made
theft under this bill
um you know it is entirely reasonable
that a board might say hey we acted in
good faith this is our understanding of
the law we consulted with an attorney
the attorney said yes that is reasonable
this law specifically addresses
um if the board of Selectmen instead of
doing this properly going into a closed
meeting discussing it
um you know perhaps taking advice from
an attorney and then voting four to one
um saying yes let's defend this lawsuit
uh that is currently legal and would
remain legal the scenario that this bill
addresses is when the board of Selectmen
meets at one selectman's house uh not
recorded not an official meeting
um and says you know we need to have the
secret meeting because we all know
what's wrong
um you know we all know that this
defense is really iffy it's a Hail Mary
pass probably the guy's gonna win but
you know Joe the plumber is my cousin
he's your you know high school friend
Etc let's do this solid for him at least
show that we're trying
um and you know then if we lose you know
uh at least no one will know that we
voted for uh this uh expenditure
recognize for follow-up thank you so my
understanding of the way Town ordinances
and New Hampshire law is and again I'm
not an attorney and I'm also new to all
of this but
is that secret meetings are actually
explicitly prohibited by law and Statute
in which case they would be acting
outside the purview of their committee
which would not then give them
protection so I still don't understand
why this would be necessary it seems to
me to be I'm just trying to sorry I
think that's an excellent question um
and and that question speaks to exactly
the intent of the bill
um it is illegal uh to have a secret
meeting
um but the question is what are the
incentives on the board um if you know
let's say that they choose to have that
secret meeting you know they twist their
wax mustaches and say yes we're all you
know gathered together to do something
villainous here we know we're breaking
the law
um but still we all agree that uh you
know let's have the secret meeting let's
authorize the town attorney uh let's pay
taxpayer dollars to do Joe the plumber
this a salad
um now what let's say that happens and a
check is written it's handed to the
attorney the case goes to court the town
either wins or lose
um and then a citizen you know says hey
uh I have read RSA 91a I know that
closed meetings
um are legal especially in this
particular case but that minutes and
vote totals must be kept and those
minutes and vote totals must be released
at the conclusion of the lawsuit so
great the lawsuit is over I would like
to see so that I can vote uh for you
know people who are making good
decisions and vote against people who
are making bad decisions I would like to
see that vote total please please show
me the minutes
and the answer is you know LOL there are
no minutes there's no vote total uh you
don't get to know what we did at that uh
illegal meeting
um the only remedy under current law is
that a citizen can sue under RSA 91a
they can you know reach into their own
pocket they can pull out ten or twenty
thousand dollars they can go to court
and they can win at which point the
judge will say uh board that had this
illegal meeting please hand over minutes
if any of your decision
um and uh minutes if any of the meeting
and the board says okay we understand
but there were no minutes at this point
the money of the taxpayer money has
already been spent the lawsuit has
already taken place uh the citizen who
had to you know prosecute the underlying
lawsuit uh you know is out of pocket so
um just because something is illegal
doesn't mean that there's any incentives
to stop the board from doing it and
that's exactly what this is attempting
to patch
thank you for taking my question and
thank you madam chair
um I was under the impression that
um vote totals and minutes weren't kept
in non-public sessions is that the case
um that is not my understanding
um I believe and I don't have the Clause
at hand right now
um but there is a clause in RSA 91a it's
you know the third or fourth paragraph
and it specifically says that in the
case of
close meetings for the purpose of
Defending a lawsuit so we might both be
right in different subsections so for
example if it's a closed meeting to
decide you know what should we do about
the police chief uh you know we think
that he's hitting on employees
um you know I I'm not sure if minutes
and votes are kept for that but I am
quite convinced uh that they are kept
for decisions about engaging in lawsuits
and it is explicitly the case that they
must be released after the conclusion of
the lawsuit
so to answer that they they keep very
very vague minutes for any kind of
non-public and I I do believe that they
do keep they do keep votes and then in
the event that they're ever unsealed
then they have the information but
they're very very big
representative Muse
yeah so hey I just want to stand
corrected in the in the bill the bill
references RSA 63711
um uh and that specific
um uh part of it of the applicable Parts
shall be guilty of theft by a public
servant and subject to the penalties in
RSA 637-11
for an expense larger than fifteen
hundred dollars that's a class B felony
so it is not just a civil issue it is a
criminal issue
um and for an offense where the sum
total is larger than a thousand dollars
uh it's a Class A misdemeanor
so um
I guess my question for you is is uh
do you think we should be criminalizing
um the behavior that this Behavior
arises to number one to a to a criminal
behavior and do you think that this
penalty is appropriate for volunteers
that is uh an excellent question
um and uh I would say that on the one
hand it's volunteers but on the other
hand uh it's a paid position
um so but uh the intent here was not
specific penalties
um you know in general uh we set
incentives not because or penalties not
because we want to collect them but
because we want people to be aware that
there is a hard line that they shouldn't
cross so you know for example we had a
road that doesn't have a speed limit on
it we might choose to put a you know 50
mile an hour speed limit there not
because we are hoping to get lots of
fines but just to make aware of what the
boundaries are and you know then ideally
we would hope that we never once catch
anyone bringing it that's the goal the
goal is not to punish people
um so uh you know in in my ideal version
this bill would be passed and then it
would never actually result in anything
speaking specifically to the size of the
penalties much of what I'm aiming for
could be accomplished just as well with
a 500 penalty as a you know class B
felony or something
um I uh again depended on OLS and
probably didn't express my intent
crisply to them I would be happy to
amend this and I would love to hear any
feedback about what would seem to be an
appropriate level of penalty that
expresses the intent of the law and the
importance of having open and responsive
government without you know certainly
holding 10 years in jail or 50 000 fine
over somebody
thank you thank you
are there any other questions from the
committee representative Newman
I apologize for being late but you can
see the reasons why out the window
I have some confusion it sounds like
there may be criminal penalties
but it looks like the entire section of
section two is that any citizen can take
action and you may have said this before
I came in and I apologize if you did
to challenge uh take it it sounds like
they take it to court and then get some
kind of remuneration for that and and
whatever so so at least partially even
though it falls under something that has
a criminal penalty this is like one of
some of the laws that have recently be
passed that that takes this kind of
thing out of the purview of the courts
and puts it into the purview of any
private citizen that wants to take a
civil action uh that's an excellent
question correct in that yeah that's an
excellent point and I again played I'm
an engineer not a lawyer so I think that
this is something that definitely needs
to be tidied up via Amendment the intent
to have civil action uh is definitely on
there um so that you know citizens just
as with RSA 91a can push for uh you know
some sort of resolution without having
to depend on third parties but I
entirely understand that uh it is not
the purview of private citizens to uh
you know push for criminal penalties
um and so I would like to speak to oh
less and come up with something that
resolves that and uh
can I have a follow-up recognize
um and in in the first part of it it
says so it's a person who authorizes or
attempts to authorize a defense
um and I don't know if then it says to
pay they have to pay for it or or not
um I guess if you have if does the
person have to be authorized
the person who does the deed of talking
about or raise or discussing it looks
like even a defense
or something
uh
I'm just confused whether whether that
person has to be authorized in the
organization that he's in to be able to
make payments or or does that even
factor in at all uh that is a great
question uh thank you for it uh and I
think that this is another thing that I
need to work with ol us on and uh
clarify what the appropriate approach
here is thank you
representative prowl
so I I came in late in
you don't want them to defend
a member of the town or no uh that's a
great question
um
under current law and under uh the
proposal of this bill it is absolutely
legal for a town to defend against any
lawsuit and they can deliberate on it
they can choose to defend they can
choose not to defend they can choose to
defend to The Bitter End defending it
you know appeal after appeal all the way
to the Supreme Court
um that is absolutely reasonable for a
town to do
um and would remain legal the uh problem
that this addresses is that sometimes
towns know that they have a bit of a
stinker of a case and the individual
board members who uh are in the position
of authorizing or not authorizing a
defense you know might want to spend
some money to show a buddy that they're
collaborating with hey I've got your
back we're going to fight this to The
Bitter End but they might not want that
to be public later you know the Best of
Both Worlds where they're doing one
thing but uh if citizens later say hey
we spent twenty five thousand dollars uh
authorizing this insane thing we got
slapped down by the judge we the town
who's behind this because when I go to
the polls in March I want to make sure
that I'm you know electing Selectmen who
are responsible stewards of our tax
dollars
under current law
um once a lawsuit is concluded the
deliberations about defending that
lawsuit and authorizing the expenditure
are public information however it is
possible for board members to violate
that law they can say Hey you know let's
not meet at Town Hall let's not turn the
cameras on let's all meet in my sun room
and figure out what we're going to do
about this we know we're going to lose
but at least Joe the plumber who's my
cousin and your high school buddy he'll
know that we did everything we could and
you know sure it's going to cost twenty
five thousand dollars but it's not like
we're going to have to pay that right
now that can happen and then the lawsuit
loses and then the citizen who was
trying to you know get his uh child you
know special remedies or there's a
zoning dispute or you know Contracting
says great I want to know who spent that
money and the answer is oh there are no
records we did it in a secret meeting
and you can say Okay RSA 91a says that I
can get the details of that and the
answer is we didn't keep any notes
um and then he says you know and also I
spent to prosecute this lawsuit against
you I spent 25 000 what happens do I get
that money back and the answer is nope
it's done we just had a secret meeting
we authorized expenditures in this
illegal secret meeting and there's
nothing a citizen can do about it you
can't even vote against us next time
because you don't know who did it
okay thanks appreciate that thank you
representative Muse
but in that example
um couldn't the citizen file a complaint
that the right to know law was violated
in that case absolutely and uh this was
a question that I think representative
selig asked earlier he could file a
complaint and
what under current law what happens with
that complaint so first of all you don't
file a complaint under RSA 91a you
launch a lawsuit under 91a you can then
go to court the citizen can reach into
his own pocket spend fifteen thousand
dollars the judge can say yes clearly uh
there should have been minutes there
should have been a vote recorded it
should now be publicized so you know
Board of selectment or planning board
please publicize those minutes tell this
citizen what he wants to know tell him
who voted for that expenditure and the
board you know Smiles at Cheshire Cat
grin and says oh there are no notes
and the judge says okay well I did what
I could and then the citizen asks judge
you know I spent twenty thousand dollars
to you know deal with the zoning issue
or whatever went to court
um they had a secret meeting they uh
expended uh taxpayer funds in this
secret meeting now there's absolutely
nothing they're saying they don't know
who did it that money doesn't go back to
the taxpayers what do I get judged what
do the taxpayers get and the judge says
you know I'm sorry citizen under RSA 91a
everything that could be done has been
done we asked them to reveal minutes and
they told us there are no minutes that's
the end of it
follow up
I understand the the hypothetical
situation
um what I'm also curious about is
whether there's actually any data on how
often this happens that's an excellent
question
um I have you know knowledge of a couple
of times it has happened locally and
that's one of the things that motivated
me to run for the house
um I have done a lot of lay research
reading Supreme Court New Hampshire
Supreme Court uh cases and I've spoken
to local attorneys
um and the answer is oh yes stuff like
this happens but you know when someone
says yes this happens and yeah I had a
client up in you know Milford or you
know in Henniker or something that's
happened to that's an anecdote it's true
um but it's not hard data and uh you
know I'm an engineer so I always like
hard data much more than a story you
know a friend told me that his cousin
you know had this happen so I wanted to
walk in here with a list of here 73
times that this has happened
unfortunately uh there does not seem to
be an easy way to get hard numbers on
that
um
thank you
just uh
quick question I thought you had to come
out of non-public session and for a vote
I didn't think you could take a vote in
non-public session
I'm not sure if that's the case or not
um but in either case we are we're
getting to the exact same thing uh
apparently you know there's the
situation whether you're allowed to or
not you get into a situation where votes
are taken in things that are neither
public sessions nor non-public sessions
they are illegal meetings and
expenditures are authorized in those
meetings so you know uh if your
statement is wait that doesn't sound
right to me I don't think they're
allowed to do that I entirely agree with
you
represent the Senate of Roy
thank you madam chairman thank you for
taking my question
so is he is it your position that while
91a
exists and dictates what they may or may
not do it has no teeth if they decide
we're just not going to follow that
that's an excellent question uh it has
two or three teeth
um and so the teeth specifically that it
has is
um as a citizen you can sue and say hey
there may or may not be records and
you're trying to hide them from me
please give me those records and if you
go through the laborious and expensive
and stressful process and if you win you
can get the records
um that doesn't help so here's you know
one tooth that is missing it doesn't
help if there are no records and here's
the second thing if actions were
authorized there is no way to undo those
actions so if you know to make up a
crazy thing if there was a taking we
decided that we wanted this Farmer's
field to put in a football uh field
instead and we did that
um and then the farmer sued and we went
to court and everything and we want to
know you know who is behind all of this
and the answer is oh we were very
careful to not take any records so great
you don't get your records and second
the farmer says well can I have my field
back now the answer is no that's done
well okay can I at least have my you
know forty thousand dollars in legal
fees back now nope that's spent can the
citizens have the thirty thousand
dollars that they uh spent or um and the
answer is nope that's spent as well so
it's uh there was a question earlier
about do we really want to criminalize
and make a class B felony out of uh
things and and I agree to that and uh we
really you know don't want to have
massive penalties I would not want a law
that's going to let some volunteer who
maybe got in a little over their head
suddenly is you know paying a hundred
thousand dollars in fines
um but I think that by having uh some
you know I don't want to quite say token
but you know uh relatively small fine to
make it clear that this is a boundary
that you know if you want to take Farmer
Joe's field for a parking lot do it on
the up and up you know have the uh
Integrity to at least have your vote
recorded in a closed meeting so that
when it's all done later that'll come
out and you know you should be proud of
and defend your vote on that so this is
only about sort of egregious cases
what
um and and pardon me for not having um
had time to read it through yet I I too
I'm a little bit late
is there any way that the penalties you
are proposing would fall back on the
taxpayers the intent here is
specifically not it is very specifically
because that's the problem it tries to
solve and so you know I would hate to
say hey the taxpayers are uh getting a
raw deal let's give them a second Raw
Deal to make it better
um so uh the intent is that this is
um a an action committed by an
individual who serves on a board and the
consequences should fall on that there
was uh like I said one question about
the size of the penalties and that's
certainly something I need to address
and there was another excellent question
about sort of a weird mismatch between
civil and criminal and that also needs
to be addressed but um as I work with
OLS uh I will certainly keep as the core
issue you know something you and I both
agree on apparently uh that these should
not fall on the taxpayers
Senator Newman
so I the the last thing I'd like to ask
you about is
what what is an example of or or an
explanation of who the who the people
are it sounds like there are two or more
people who are yeah two or more people
who who are on some legislative
organization and they get together and
there's three of them
and two of them say I think we ought to
start a lawsuit in the third one says no
I don't
and they say well we took a vote and
we're going to go ahead with this
lawsuit so they go ahead with a lawsuit
and I don't know whether they win it or
lose it I'm not sure I heard that but
but but then what happens the the uh the
money that comes from the municipality
has to be in my opinion has to be voted
on by the municipality I don't know how
they how they wiggle their way into a
non-session or whatever how did they do
that in right so this is an excellent
question someone else asked a question
uh in the similar vein uh you know and
the question was effectively you know
hey that's illegal they can't do that so
what is it you know specifically that
you're trying to address with us and and
I'm agreeing with you yes that's exactly
correct that um a bunch of board of
Selectmen for example meeting at a
coffee house or in someone's sun room
um and having a off the Record uh
discussion and vote that is neither in a
uh open meeting nor in a closed meeting
cannot authorize the expenditure of
taxpayer funds to defend against a
lawsuit they can't do it the law says
they can't do it but the question is say
they do it anyway and the town attorney
says okay you know I I got the phone
call from the head of the BOS the head
of the BOS says that they want me to
defend the planning boards or the zoning
boards decision to put in a oil refinery
in the middle of a you know um you know
park or whatever
um you know that shouldn't happen we
absolutely agree uh and yet um it's
something that can happen there's you
know we've got laws but there's no you
know law of physics that stops these
people from doing it that phone call
from being made that check from being
signed so the question is when such a
sequence of events happens uh what
remedy do citizens have afterwards and
that's what this bill speaks to address
just follow up
and my follow-up would be they can't
authorize it in the private they can't
authorize it in the off-site non-public
session so they have to get into and not
they'd have to get into a non-public
session to do that to get the
authorization they could they couldn't
just make the phone call from their
meeting at work I understand the
question and I'm not even sure it's
criminal because now it's the solution
apparently from the bill is that it's
it's a civil thing that anybody can
whether whether or not and you might
want to clarify this portion of it does
the person can anybody in the state of
New Hampshire who just thinks it's a bad
idea get into civil court with this
because it says anybody can do that or
maybe am I misreading that
um that was excellent I believe there's
two questions there the first question
sorry
the first question was
um
the first was basically a statement and
the statement was but current law does
not allow a POS
um to meet and without going into either
open or closed session authorize
expenditure of funds for the defense of
a lawsuit I 100 agree with you current
law does not authorize that to happen
current law also doesn't authorize you
know Murder or burglary and yet those
things happen so the question is when an
illegal action like that happens what is
the remedy and this bill seeks to
provide a remedy for a thing that should
never happen because it's illegal but a
thing that does happen the second
question was who does this bill
authorize to push for enforcement and
your observation was that it says uh I'm
not sure what line number but something
you know any person that is intentional
and that is part of it so that you know
uh if you know Joe the plumber was an
example earlier if Joe the plumber has a
back room deal he is you know get some
spot zoning so they can park trucks in
the middle of a residential area
um the zoning board gives him you know
spot zoning approval even though spot
zoning has been illegal The Neighbor
Next Door you know uh goes through the
political process in the town the BOS
says you know we've heard your
objections but we don't care the citizen
then sues the BOS meets in secret
session and authorized expenditure of
taxpayer dollars to defend a clearly
losing lawsuit
um and then after it's all over
um you know under this bill there's the
The Proposal of what can a citizen do
um to you know enforce the fact that the
BOS should not be having secret meetings
and illegally authorizing expenditures
and so the any person could speak to the
one citizen who originally filed uh the
lawsuit it could speak to another
citizen who is like-minded and lives on
the other side of Joe the plumber it
good Etc
thank you
are there any further questions from the
committee
all right
seeing none thank you very much thank
you for some excellent questions is
there anybody here no
all right we will close the public
hearing on House Bill 292.
okay being uh 10 47 we're going to open
the public hearing on HB
e302 FN
and recognize representative love to
answer this is Bill
thank you Mr Chim Madam Madam Vice chair
and the rest of the committee up here in
my my testimony here um I uh
I'm here to
to introduce House Bill 302 a bill that
would uh
make uh constitutional training uh more
more stringent and uh and uh you know a
better a better
better training for for our police
officers
um I I thought about this idea uh a
couple of years ago a year and a half
ago or so while we were at uh the
Bedford state house uh
we uh we we voted on a bill to uh to
eliminate qualified immunity for our law
enforcement and uh you know coming from
a law enforcement family I I knew that
wasn't a good idea
um I I don't want I don't want our
offices out there uh second guessing
every move they make
but anyway I did I went to a seminar and
uh you know it was about qualified
immunity and it was mostly all people
that wanted to get rid of it uh you know
the ACLU lawyers and stuff and uh that
one of their one of their main
objections was the lack of
constitutional knowledge by our police
officers you know these are the guys
that are here to enforce the
Constitution and uh you know they felt
that uh you know that they they didn't
have enough training in it so I put this
bill together I I spoke to uh to John
cipa about a year ago about it and he
and I just spoke and uh you know uh we
uh we we both kind of agree that you
know that you know constitutional
training for for law enforcement is a
good idea and um you know the the the uh
the difference of opinion that we have
and I'm not uh I wouldn't object to uh
to knocking down the the eight hours
that I have here uh down a six or
whatever uh you know whatever would be
appropriate but we just need better
training and um you know it's it's to
fend off the uh the attack on on
qualified immunity uh is the the reason
I put this together
and uh that would be about it
thank you for that um I'll take the
first question have you conferred with
um with um director skippa and asked
that they do have constitutional uh law
and training as part of their Academy
correct yes they do and uh you know the
the uh you know the opinion of uh those
at that seminar and uh you know direct
us on a skipper doesn't uh doesn't seem
to be too averse to you know adding a
little more uh and uh you know we've
just got to do better uh you know uh
We've uh I was just talking to him about
an instance uh my brother
um we both Drive limos and uh two
o'clock in the morning he was pulled
over uh a a cop pulled up behind him
with the bright lights on and all the
rest and blinding them and so he just
pulled over and to let him buy didn't
know he was a cop and uh you know he got
read the riot act and you know have you
been drinking you're all over the road
well you know when you when you've got
bright lights shining in your eyes uh
you tend to do that and uh you know my
my brother my brother been sober for 25
five years at the time but anyway you
know it was a you know it's something
that shouldn't have happened and um you
know uh the the if the officer had more
training and and stuff maybe of
um you know I've talked to other other
guys I drive with and uh that they have
the same problems in some of the small
towns uh you know so uh you know if we
have some some better constitutional
training you know for the people that
are there to enforce the Constitution uh
I think New Hampshire would be a better
place
thank you
representative Muse
thank you very much
um the Constitution is a really big
document and uh eight hours isn't a heck
of a lot of time
um
are there particular areas of focus you
would like to see the training
um zero in on
thank you for the question absolutely uh
you know it's written here the Bill of
Rights okay uh the the I don't think
police officers need to know Commerce
law and election law and stuff let you
know let's let's focus on the Bill of
Rights
Representative no
so
um specifically if you're talking about
the Bill of Rights I mean that's pretty
short
um piece of it right
um and if there's already training I'm
just wondering what kind of feedback you
got as far as
um is it is it the training that's
lacking or is it kind of you know the
testing the the demonstration of of that
knowledge
thanks for the question it's a good
question huh well
I guess it wouldn't be very fair to uh
to to test somebody on something that
they haven't been trained on so uh you
know that the training is uh is
necessary uh you know I um
you know it'd be more thorough some some
might have enough to get through a test
and uh you know and score maybe a 70 but
I I'd like our law enforcement to be
able to score you know 95 to 100 and if
they have the training they can
thank you I think at this point um it
would probably be best to hear from
director Skipper thank you very much for
um bringing this bill oh I'm sorry
absolutely just if it's I think we
pretty much know what he knows so
go ahead
I I was just trying to understand the
connection to qualified immunity
um and your bill I I misunderstood your
your connection between those I'm really
sorry
there is a push to get rid of qualified
immunity do you understand what
qualified immunity is okay uh there's a
there's a push we did have a bill I'm
not sure if it was last year the year
before
um
it was a close vote and um you know I I
think it'd be disastrous for law
enforcement it'd be disaster disasters
for society in general uh and
represent scitec I don't want to
protract this but you may be headed in
the wrong direction here's why I can't
imagine a patrolman saying to his
Sergeant you've just asked me to do
something unconstitutional because I've
just read this I had a training I just
that's not how line command works in the
police department I have some experience
with that would you comment on that what
what how can how can you tell your your
Lieutenant no you're wrong that's what
the courts are for
that's my concern
if I was a police officer thanks for the
question if I was a police officer and I
was being asked to do something
unconstitutional uh I'd certainly have a
record of it and uh if it's a lieutenant
I'd ask a captain
thank you I think the answer to that
question is not is not part of this bill
this is the training part as far as how
the Departments handle that I think is
an internal matter that this doesn't
reach to thank you for your testimony
and at this point I'm called director
skippa
foreign
thank you Mr chair uh good morning
honorable members of this committee uh
for the record my name is John skippa
I'm the director of New Hampshire police
standards and training we are the sole
source for recruit training here for
every single law enforcement agent here
in the state of New Hampshire and we
also serve as the primary source for
incumbent or in-service police training
throughout the state of New Hampshire as
well
uh thank you for your uh you're allowing
me to uh come and just share uh some of
my thoughts on this particular Bill uh
and and Mr chair I would ask if I uh
pass something along to this committee
does it become a public record it does
okay uh and so in that case I will not
pass the document around only because it
contains uh test information and a
facilitator guide uh for the actual
block of instruction but I hold here uh
our uh
60 uh check that 12 hour class on
constitutional law which is delivered at
every recruit Training Academy that we
deliver in New Hampshire
uh this this was compiled and built by
one of my training Specialists who is a
uh an attorney as well as a certified
police officer
the uh this lesson uh is not only
lecture based but also scenario based
yes
if I could I I thought your intention
was to give a handout if you want to
just pass that around to let folks look
at it it doesn't become part of the
public record excellent thank you yeah
I would ask every member if you have an
opportunity to look at the table of
contents because it clearly sets forth
each module of the entire lesson plan uh
this lesson plan
speaks directly to those constitutional
aspects that a law enforcement officer
is going to need to know and and to
representative loves uh position there
are there are portions of these
documents that are just not relevant to
law enforcement uh and so we concentrate
our efforts on those areas that are
specific to law enforcement activities
we we speak not only to the Federal
Constitution and the state constitution
uh certainly Bill of Rights but we also
talk about historical data as well and
and some of the um
uh just human rights that came before
any Constitution did we really want to
build out a strong foundation with these
recruits with regard to those aspects of
constitutional law that they're going to
be working with every single day that
they go out on the street
I would like to share with you that
um
I am extremely proud of this work
product that's going around the table
and in fact next month I have been
invited to participate in a national
study
uh for uh
directors of law enforcement standards
and training internationally uh where I
I'm going to be attending a program on
the development of best practice for
teaching constitutional and procedural
Justice that will lay out uh really kind
of a framework on a national level with
regard to teaching the Constitution to
new police recruits and I've already
forwarded this document to the committee
as we prepare to to have these
discussions and already I've received a
tremendous amount of uh really accolades
to pass along to the person that
developed this this is I in my opinion
is serves as a as an example Nationwide
on how we should be teaching
constitutional law to to recruit
officers
it's also important to understand that
particularly with teaching adults
lecture is not the best way to get the
point across you really want to create
opportunities where you give adults fact
patterns and let them work through it
themselves have that that open
discussion
try to come to the appropriate decision
in a safe environment right through
scenario training in group group
projects those laminated cards that are
going to follow that lesson plan and
facilitators guide are actual scenarios
that we use at the Academy to teach
those recruits as they go through this
program
I would look forward to I would welcome
the opportunity to work with uh
representative love and really anybody
in this state quite frankly
if there is a concern that we are not
providing the best instruction that we
can provide to our police officers
particularly with regard to
constitutional law I stand ready to work
with anyone and I I was lucky enough to
have a conversation with representative
love before testimony began I I
certainly would look forward to sitting
down and working with him to see
uh maybe the shortcomings that he he
might have in his mind uh whether we are
addressing those shortcomings that that
he believes exists uh and if they do
exist then let us work to uh to make a
phenomenal lesson plan even better quite
frankly
um
my other concern is it's important to
teach the content
hours uh is just checking a box if you
if the two hours of instruction it might
be 45 minutes of content
it could be four hours of content you're
trying to shove in a you know a two-hour
Block it's important for me and for my
staff to make sure that we are
representing uh appropriately as we
teach these uh topics not only
constitutional law but any law uh or any
block of instruction that we are
valuing the time of the student and
we're valuing the time of the home
agency that is paying that student to be
in that seat studying uh
to become a police officer in the state
of New Hampshire and so I was very
concerned when there was uh actual hours
attached uh to this bill and and again
uh I I certainly look forward to working
with representative love and and
any other person in the state of New
Hampshire who thinks that we need to to
revisit what we're doing here and I
stand ready to to respond to any
questions
thank you director did representative
love have an opportunity to look at
these yet like uh not yet we've
literally just uh saw each other we've
talked on the phone a couple of times
for the first time we've met so uh not a
chance yet thank you
um how how is how do you um
the course material is good how do you
ensure that they're understanding the
testing process that that they've
absorbed this and they know it thank you
very much and it's an excellent question
uh you know written tests are just that
they're written tests and and uh
genuinely you're measuring the student's
recall
that's all you're doing is you're
measuring their ability to remember
things
it's more important for us to make sure
that they can as the representative
spoke to actually perform
comprehend understand
negotiate to the correct answer and
that's why it's vitally important for
those scenario and group trainings to
take place we measure on a written test
which is included in the back portion of
that facilitator's guide but we also
measure through a grading rubric that's
been designed by our curriculum
coordinator
to make sure that when they do these
scenarios and they do these group
projects
that they're able to take a fact pattern
uh that may be murky because let's all
agree that uh uh being a cop is it's a
murky job it's there's not a lot of
bright lines and you really have to to
be a problem solver so put these young
people into groups let them take those
murky facts let them work through it
have discussions come to the to the
answer that they need to come to and
then be able to defend why did you come
to this answer why do you think this is
the best approach
uh and it's always fun to let them
defend their position in front of their
peers that's where the best discussions
happen because they're uh they're pretty
tough on each other too so it's a good
learning experience
um also I would ask
constitutional laws you know
um Can Change by the minute sometimes
how do you address it once they've left
your Academy how do you how do you make
sure that they're keeping up with it
thank you for that question as well uh
one of the things in candidly
um uh kind of fell off of our radar uh
right around when covet hit
uh was that we provided uh a an annual
law update it was it was really just a
flyer it was no more than a flyer it is
my intention to uh create an annual
in-service program that they every
officer can complete online to include
testing
with legal updates New Hampshire legal
updates that is something that our state
has never mandated uh but it's something
that I would like to Institute in 2023
we we now have the staff to be able to
put that together and so to address
those types of concerns as well as just
changes in in motor vehicle law and uh
you know training and things of that
nature I think it's very important to
send out the consistent clear message uh
and and attach a a testing component to
it as well and we can do that through
our online learning Bureau
does is there currently an insurance
requirement that they have every year
uh there is not uh we have uh in
mandatory in-service
uh training hours that are required but
we do leave a fair amount of that to the
Chief Executive Officer of each agency
to determine what would be the best way
to spend those training dollars for that
particular Community uh candidly uh I I
I think it is important that we create
uh in conjunction with the Attorney
General's office and we have a great
working relationship with the AG's
office to create that annual legal
update and we deliver it in a very uh
you know defined way
in in my last question your agency that
has anything to do with officer uh
discipline or issues that occur later
with their licensure
um
there was a scenario brought up about
you know if someone was ordered to do
something unconstitutional can you just
speak to that shortly if you could
absolutely chair uh and thank you for
that question uh as of January 1st of
this year uh
New Hampshire police standards and
training now has a very clearly
organized conduct Review Committee that
has been established to address any
allegation of defined police misconduct
under RSA 106-l
uh
being given an unconstitutional order uh
could very well fall under that
committee's review
certainly uh an unconstitutional act by
a police officer is going to in the
first instance negate any law
enforcement action that they took and
certainly would open them to civil
penalty uh for conducting that kind of
unconstitutional act and it could very
well expose them to criminal liability
as well
representative Newman
yeah I just have a quick question you
mentioned you mentioned 12 hours of
training when you first began your
testimony was that 12 hours in
constitutional training or was that I
haven't seen the documents yet or is
that a bigger piece of stuff so uh thank
you for that question I looked at the
first part which looks like it went
article by article where you know the
Fifth Amendment and all the amendments
are important about searches and whatnot
thank you for that question the 12-hour
block of instruction is to deliver the
lecture and to apply the scenario
training for constitutional law uh it's
also important to understand while we
have this block of instruction on
constitutional law that builds the
foundation I can tell you that right now
I just left I I was monitoring a class
that was being delivered by a member of
the Attorney General's office and that's
an eight-hour block on search and
seizure
so we introduce the notion of
protections under the Fourth Amendment
and part one Article 19 of our state
constitution relative to searches
seizures and the arrest of people
but that these students get that uh
reinforced every time we have a separate
class we have a class on laws of arrest
that's another eight hours that builds
off of the 12-hour block of
constitutional law we have an eight-hour
class on search and seizure again that
revisits all of the foundation class of
the Constitutional law class uh when we
talk about defensive tactics and they're
down there uh you know rolling around
with each other and pinning each other
to the ground there is a discussion both
on the Constitutional application of
force
and and the ethical application of force
as well we have we build in blocks of
instruction relative to ethics in in
every one of our classes as well uh
again it's um they're going to eat this
elephant but they do it in very small
bites throughout the 16-week academy uh
and I hope that answers your question
sir
foreign
follow-up to that and it was kind of uh
the Genesis of it might have been the
question about
what a police officer does in uh when
they think they're being asked to do
something that's unconstitutional so
it's a command a person that is in
authority and then being told to do
something that you're not quite sure of
and it could be like the famous case
where someone was killed and there were
three officers working and and you have
a a an instructor you know his boss and
just came out of instruction and all of
that kind of stuff is there training in
there in your uh organization to address
things that you might have been divulged
to by that kind of situation absolutely
thank you for the question yes uh again
uh there are uh there's statutory
requirements for police officers to
report
misconduct uh that is uh alleged to have
occurred by another police officer that
is RSA 105 19. uh and that that requires
officers to report uh uh specific
allegations of misconduct that they
actually Witness
you know I'll tell you a funny story
when I very first started as a police
officer uh I graduated from the Academy
I went back to my home agency and
was talking about a situation with a you
know over a coffee there was a bunch of
us sitting around and and my boss came
in and I respected the guy very much and
he said well you could have just
arrested him and held him for four hours
and
um in fact many many years ago I'm not
going to tell you how many years ago
because it was a long time ago but uh
you actually could do that until a New
Hampshire Supreme Court case uh dictated
that uh you cannot arrest somebody and
hold them for four hours without having
probable cause to make that arrest uh
and and I I share that with this
committee because that's an excellent
example of how a police officer who's
now in a position of authority they they
believe that they are acting uh with
best knowledge and in fact there's been
a change in law that they're not aware
of uh and and candidly to representative
loves uh response
in the first instance that younger
officers should ask for review by a
higher up and if he needs to go by or
she needs to go by
that supervisor to the captain as
representative love said that's the very
first step to fix that immediately uh
and and certainly you know if they can't
get it fixed uh they can reach out to us
and we can address it as well
thank you representative Newell
um so I'm curious I I know I well I
guess it is kind of a two-parter
question but it just goes really quick
too
um
I'm guilty of all these all the time
okay
um first of all how long has this
particular module been in use
I believe it is on the cover uh and uh I
and I'm only saying that because I can't
uh I can't remember uh but this came out
of uh recommendations from uh the liac
commission which
seems like yesterday but I believe it
was a couple of years ago when that
summary report was issued and uh one of
one of the steps that I took was to
Corral my folks and say show me what we
have we need to do better let's let's
build this out better and that uh that
is a result of of that directive so
probably the last couple years
um the second part of my question is
um
is there I know that you know we already
spoke to kind of can what I would call
continuing education just because of the
you know professions I've been in
um and that being in the process of
being made and that would be for updates
and things like that my question is for
people who have been in the police force
for much longer than that module has
been in use did they then go back I know
that this is in the training academy so
this would be something you know first
first training is there you know has
there traditionally been the opportunity
for um for officers who maybe didn't go
through this you know comprehensive and
thorough module to go back and get that
same education that's a thank you for
that question it's an excellent question
candidly there's no mechanism to uh
provide that opportunity to come back
that doesn't mean that we can't just
offer this 12-hour block of instruction
as an in-service program and allow uh
any police officer in the state of New
Hampshire corrections officer in the
state of New Hampshire state corrections
officer to attend that particular
in-service program I will I will tell
you that um
uh anecdotally uh we are crushed for uh
space in our building and we have a very
small teaching staff
uh and so that that also becomes part of
the overall discussion is uh making sure
that we're allocating resources
appropriately to to get the biggest bang
for our for our buck uh and that's why
we see the development of online
training programs to be the best way to
address uh pushing that
as you spoke to that you know kind of
that you've been on for 10 15 20 years
uh
you know take take uh maybe not 12 hours
online that would be a long time but
maybe we we chop it up into smaller
bites of an hour or two because then
that officer can do it on duty they can
come in and have have their meal sit in
front of the computer and bang that out
quick and it also helps them maintain
kind of uh their in-service requirements
they would get credit for for uh you
know completing that so
wait you've you've helped me maybe uh
look at a different way of uh building
out the in-service thank you
actually yeah representative means
you'll be last
thank you very much I I know one issue
that's come up across the country and
I'm wondering if it has come up here at
all in New Hampshire uh is the issue of
of some officers believing that they
have
um Supreme legal Authority and the power
and duty to disregard laws that they
regard as unconstitutional
um are you instructing how are you
instructing officers in the academy when
it comes to that I'm sure that many of
the officers are aware of that situation
and and how do you think it plays into
this conversation
uh thank you for the question I would
ask for clarification I'm not uh in it I
apologize some of it I didn't hear
uh can you give me a specific example
sure I think that across the country
there have been folks that have called
themselves uh Sovereign sheriffs
um and when it comes to enforcing uh
things like Firearms laws and things and
and things of that nature
um they've sometimes taken upon taken it
upon themselves to interpret the
Constitution that that that all those
laws are unconstitutional uh whether
they're federal or state and they refuse
to enforce them I'm just curious what
what the policy is on that in New
Hampshire
thank you for that question and thank
you for the clarification as well uh
candidly speaking uh
New Hampshire
uh
the common sense
that is found as part of the Bedrock of
this state uh not only permeates
throughout our state but through our New
Hampshire law enforcement community
uh
you see
those types of situations generally with
constitutional officers those officers
that are elected by the people
uh here in New Hampshire I have never
heard I know all of the sheriffs I meet
with them monthly at their Association
meetings that is not uh that does not
exist within the elected sheriffs here
uh in New Hampshire I've never heard of
a sheriff speak that way
they are presently every sheriff is a
certified police officer in the state of
New Hampshire
constitutionally it's not necessitated
but they all feel it's important to be
certified as a police officer as well
uh and I have never heard of that type
of discussion or position by any of our
elected law enforcement officials here
in New Hampshire
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I was just wondering so in the bill
it talks about
um eight hours of training as well on
the New Hampshire Constitution as a New
Hampshire Constitution addressed in this
curriculum or is that like a separate
module that the officers take thank you
for that question uh that is uh the New
Hampshire Constitution that is
specifically relevant to law enforcement
activities is included in that block of
instruction
uh and candidly uh I have a copy of the
New Hampshire Constitution that sits on
my desk uh and and candidly there's
probably two or three
pages of that very thick book that that
apply to
um uh law enforcement activities
actually can you describe
um uh just a little bit I think it would
be helpful kind of in the context of
this decision now that or discussion now
that I've gone ahead and raised it
um but what what kind of instruction is
currently in the 12-hour program around
the Second Amendment uh what what are we
what are we telling officers to do to
not to do to be careful of how does how
does that work
if may I refer to if you give a a short
answer that'd be okay that's really
relevant to the that's really diving
into the the weeds of this billboard go
ahead
I I think that we talk about the fact
that the Second Amendment exists uh I I
would really want to look at that to to
speak accurately to it uh
we create uh scenario training not so
much at the Constitutional Law class but
at the end of The Academy we have a what
we call a applied Patrol procedures
section
where we create a scenario where you
know there's a law-abiding citizen
that's carrying a firearm and and
um uh is protesting and and we asked the
recruits to negotiate that and and do it
in a safe way but do it in a way that
protects you know everybody's rights I
don't know if that's helpful to to
answering your question
um
it is helpful thank you very much and
and uh sir if you want to speak offline
with some other questions I'd be happy
to talk with you thank you director I
think that to answer that question might
take four hours because there's a lot
involved in that if just for the
edification of the committee and perhaps
to answer representative Muse scenario
wise
um you have a citizen walking out in
front of the state house with an AR-15
what's this what what would the officer
be trained to do in that situation yeah
so uh that that happens quite often here
in New Hampshire uh
I I
can tell you that uh people who uh
police in New Hampshire recognize that
that citizen has a right to have that
firearm uh it may be inappropriate uh in
the officer's mind personally that
somebody's bringing an AR-15 to Walmart
uh but they're they are still entitled
to do that uh the officer is going to
introduce themselves they're going to
explain why that they're they're
contacting the person who has the
firearm we've received a number of
complaints there's a lot of people that
are concerned uh I'm here to just make
sure that everything is all right you
know
um
they're generally met with I have a
right to have this I have a right to
have this we recognize that right yes
you do have a right to to have that just
understand that there's other people
that were concerned and they called us
uh you know in the end just that give
and take on the side of the road just
that discussion is enough to
um
uh provide an opportunity for the
officer to evaluate whether there is a
threat that exists or whether it's just
a law-abiding a citizen who
chooses to bring their AR-15 to Walmart
and and uh
uh and again I I spoke about it earlier
being a cop oftentimes it's murky it's a
you're you're in a gray area and you're
trying to
to do the very best you can with limited
information with people who
may not be completely Cooperative with
you so uh so the officer is trained to
do the very best they can while
protecting people's rights uh but also
keeping people safe and making sure that
crimes are not going to be committed
it's a it's quite a tightrope
we have a lot of vacancies if anybody's
interested
I believe representative love is
interested in taking your common law
class
uh thank you for your time this morning
director and thank you again
representative love for bringing us a
spill has anyone else um you're also
um thank you anyone else wishing to
testifying this bill it wasn't testified
there being none I'm going to close
public hearing
on what was this
Alex
HP 302 and the committee will be in
recess until
five minutes
foreign
it being 11 30. it's time to open the
public hearing on HB 421
and I will recognize the prime sponsor
represent every
to introduce her bill
thank you Mr chair and thank you once
again honorable members of the criminal
justice committee I can promise you it
was not my incent to come before you
three days in a row this year but I did
end up supporting Bill's uh that I was
co-sponsor on and wanted to show support
for those
so for the record my name is Ellen Reed
I represent New Market and new Fields
um and the bill before you would codify
what is already certainly in my
interpretation in most people's
interpretation uh the Constitutional
requirement that uh prisons and jails
provide basic menstruation hygiene
products for women or inmates who
menstruate so I want to just first say
that I will use the term woman I am
using that in the biological sense I am
not getting into any other political
issues I want to strictly talk about the
biological need for products to address
menstruation which is a real thing I
will say that not all women obviously
menstruate but 80 percent of women who
are incarcerated are of administration
age and so therefore when we say women
we are talking about most of the people
that we're talking about are likely to
need these products
so as I said I think that we are all
very clear both on the federal and the
state level Constitution that when we
incarcerate an individual it becomes the
responsibility of the government to
provide for their basic health and
hygiene
obviously menstruation falls under that
and when women do not have access to uh
period products it becomes an actual
health issue women and I'll speak
broadly about women what's called period
poverty who don't have access to
products in general forced to use toilet
paper napkins paper towels socks in
incarceration those products become rare
as well and so they can be forced to use
really anything they can find that is
absorbent when you're not incarcerated
and you are in this period poverty it
inhibits people from being able to
participate in Social Act activities
there's a sense of Shame obviously that
comes with that especially if though
that evidence is visible it is the same
in incarceration where women who may be
liable to have blood on their clothing
would not want to engage in the small
amount of time they get to engage in
social activities or in enrichment
activities that the facilities do
provide so
because
specifically in my bill I say as needed
as adequate for the person who's
incarcerated you might notice that
there's no fiscal note on this it's our
as I said it's already a constitutional
requirement I believe the reason after
talking with several people the reason
there is no fiscal note on this is
because first of all for the most part
jails and prisons are already providing
these products but they're not
how should I put it maybe putting the
kind of priority on the needs that is
necessary because we do have repeated
anecdotes of women who are not getting
the products in a timely manner we're
not getting products that are
appropriate or adequate for their needs
and I know that you'll hear a little bit
of that information today and or getting
it as written testimony so I won't go
into too much detail except to say that
um as I said there's sometimes uh
barriers to getting it that provide
um inadequate or inappropriate amounts
of time waiting for products uh one
person I know at least one woman in mate
in the state developed an infection from
not being provided uh the correct or
adequate products
in addition the women who are
incarcerated are overwhelmingly in
poverty or lower income people and it
turns out also lower income women are
far far more likely to have gynological
conditions that
make them more likely to need
menstruation products conditions like
PCOS where women can have extremely
heavy and extremely long periods
so I happen to know from a very personal
examples that went with PCOS can bleed
for over a year and in fact can bleed so
heavily that most products are
inadequate to the flow
uh finally I will say
oh I I just I'm sorry I missed this
point because I was just uh I got
sidetracked but the Constitutional thing
in the fiscal note uh the reason that I
don't think there's a fiscal note is
because since it's already a
constitutional mandate that we take care
of the basic health and hygiene of
people who are incarcerated that and in
fact we do sometimes but it's not being
followed adequately that there's no
extra actual money being spent and in
addition since it's already a
constitutional requirement this does not
become an unfunded mandate because it's
already a mandate if the bill were to
specify a certain amount then that might
change but the last point that I'll
bring up because I do have a couple of
experts who made their way through the
snow here today I think we originally
were supposed to have three or four
women who were going to give you their
personal experience and incarceration in
this state
unfortunately the snowstorm made it
impossible for them to come up but we do
have a couple experts that managed to
make it today and I want to thank them
so I'll end by saying this language or
language very similar to this was
already passed by 15 States including
Alabama Arizona Illinois Mississippi
North Carolina Nebraska Tennessee and
Virginia so it is a a widespread problem
that I think it doesn't hurt even though
I'm saying that it's already a
constitutional mandate that we provide
for basic health and hygiene this is a
kind of built and suspenders approach
because right now if a person who's
incarcerated experiences a problem their
only real Avenue of addressing it would
be to start a court case and and
challenge it constitutionally in which
those resources for an inmate is almost
impossible to acquire having a law will
a
um
kind of encourage the correctional
facilities to obey what we believe is
already a constitutional mandate where
they might not be taking this particular
thing very seriously at the moment and
uh and B would provide more legal action
available to people who experience a
violation of this so with that I'm I'm
open for questions
thank you representative
um when I read that this bill was coming
frankly I was shocked that it would even
be necessary and if that is the case it
um it certainly needs to be remedied as
that's barbaric
um
can you speak to some of the possible
Health implications of not being able to
take care of this I mean you can get
UTIs do you know anything about that
could you speak to that I I so a little
bit I'm not a medical doctor but
um so uh I I do know of at least one
female inmate who's developed an
infection from being given products that
were not adequate for her
um there there are a wide variety of
products that might be necessary for
example I believe Carroll County in
particular only offers pads
um and I believe and again this is
anecdotal so I'm piecing together
information from from different stories
but only one size or type of pad this
can be problematic and the largest
basically in order to kind of cover
their bases but that isn't adequate to
people with smaller bodies that can
bunch and not be comfortable and so I
know that some of the inmates there were
requesting things like tampons tampons
tend to fit a wider range of women
because women's bodies external bodies
tend to vary more so
um in terms of yes UTIs I have a female
relative who developed a UTI from
improper use and other infections as
well I believe things like yeast
infections but again I'm not a medical
doctor
and I'm sure if I don't ask someone else
will ask um if someone's going to talk
about this one of the witnesses you
don't need to but is there specific
institution or or place that this has
happened that that brought this to your
attention and if someone else is going
to talk about it personally that's fine
so I think you will get more information
from the experts the I believe and I
might be getting my stories confused
that the Carroll County was the location
of uh the person who got the infection I
believe the state tends to be a little
bit better in their practices but even
as we were researching it was hard to
get information from these facilities as
to what their actual policies were how
did women who were incarcerated acquire
materials when they needed them
it'll also add the health piece of
um inadequate if you provided too strong
of a product that could also run the
risk of toxic shock syndrome
representative scitec
question of the chairs are there any
cards from the Department of Corrections
on this
yes okay all right
there being no questions thank you for
your testimony thank you
representative Muse
just looking over your bill very quickly
one of the things you alluded to is that
women may need different types of
products I just wanted to point out in
your your bill it doesn't really address
that so the the Carroll County situation
you raised were only one type of product
is available
under your bill May the way that it's
currently written that may be an
acceptable practice I just wanted to
point that out so by one interpretation
I can see your interpretation by one
interpretation since it says any product
designed to address menstruation
then you could interpret it as perhaps
even overly broad
so I'm happy to address uh
whether within the committee on the
floor or in the senate or in a committee
of conference I'm happy to address any
language changes that are necessary
thank you very much I think we want to
solve the problem
thank you
at this time the chair will recognize
um
Daniel Popovich
can you turn the mic on
I should know that but I'm new thank you
I will try to keep my remarks as brief
as possible because there are a lot of
people here and obviously I will not
repeat any of the points already made by
the primary sponsor I just want to
address a few things first I I heard the
chairman say that he was surprised the
legislation is needed frankly that was
my first reaction when I heard about a
bill weingard's name do we need it but
the fact is that we do so the question
is how can we craft this bill to address
the issue in the you know best way
when inmates are in a you know situation
where their constitutional rights are
violated it's extremely difficult for
them to get redressed to it very few
people have the ability to mount from
you know jail a lawsuit and try to get
their rights addressed so this bill will
clarify what the obligations are and
both reduce the impact on the people
whose rights may not be respected and it
will also decrease the risk of a large
constitutional lawsuits that you know
will cost a lot of money for everybody
involved in inmates tend to use public
defender you know so all costs will be
borne by the state so in my opinion this
will definitely help in both improve the
practices and decrease legal risks for
the state which are all positive
outcomes
um the questions about you know the uh
specificity of the you know amount and
type of product is a very valid question
but if we try to be overly specific it
could end up with a fiscal note and this
is really not the year where we wanna
you know
take the risk of the finance committee
which I'm brand new on so I cannot
really speak for them but just as myself
it would be best if bills would have a
minimal fiscal impact this year whenever
that can be done while still addressing
the issue and my concern with specifying
an amount for example would be that you
get into a Goldilocks situation where
some whatever amount we specify will be
too much for some people who don't need
it and too little for other people who
need more I think that the use of the
word adequate Amounts is necessary is
really a really good way of defining
what's needed obviously the prison
wardens and the Personnel have the
ability to deny products that may be
dangerous some of the potential things
may not be suited for a jail because
they can be modified into weapons or
whatnot so
just seeing adequate's amounts of
necessary in my personal opinion allows
the
reasons to maintain their safe
environment while addressing the needs
and not you know specifying being too
specifics about the amount which would
create issues either way
I just wanted to keep it to two minutes
I think I'm reasonably close I
appreciate your time and this is my
testimony unless you have questions
thank you
thank you for your sharing testimony
it's time to chair will recognize Riley
Rodell
please feel free to correct me if I did
something horrible to your name
hello my name is Riley rowdell and I am
a high school senior from Hollis New
Hampshire I'm here today to testify on
the behalf of House Bill 421
I am also a volunteer for the
organization the period movement which
is an international organization that
seeks to eradicate period poverty in our
lifetimes and I am currently the period
Community organizer for the State of New
Hampshire
when menstruators do not have adequate
access to period products they are
forced to use products longer than
intended or attempt to make products
using materials that are available to
them
in addition to being unsanitary this
poses several physical health risks
including toxic shock syndrome
infections sepsis all of which can
ultimately lead to infertility
lack of access to period products have
been linked to mental health issues as
well period poverty is associated with
increased risks of anxiety and
depression
period poverty is limited or inadequate
access to menstrual products that can
affect people who menstruate in any Walk
of Life ensuring that it does not affect
more vulnerable segments of our
population who cannot necessarily
advocate for themselves is part of our
civic duty
Kimberly Haven a reproductive Justice
Advocate reports that during her time in
jail she witnessed women declining
visits with their families and with
their attorneys because they did not
have adequate access to menstrual
products while in their periods
ultimately this conversation comes down
to one of human dignity each one of us
deserves to be able to manage bodily
functions adequately including those who
are in prison
for nearly half of the population this
includes proper access to menstrual
products no one should be forced to risk
toxic shock syndrome sepsis infection or
infertility to manage a natural body
function
periods are not a luxury and the
products that are necessary to manage
them are not luxury items
they should be provided along with all
other necessary hygiene items such as
toilet paper to those in state or County
custody that require them
I would like to thank the sponsor of
this bill and I'd also like to note that
New Hampshire has been at the Forefront
of menstrual Equity legislation for a
few years now as some of you may know in
2019 New Hampshire was the third state
to require period products in public
middle and high schools by law
I encourage all of you to support this
essential piece of legislation and
continue to Serve and Protect the
Dignity of all those human straight
thank you all for your time and I'll
take any questions if they're already
thank you very much for your testimony
um I know would you be able to submit
that for the committee for our record
yes you can email it if that's your only
copy or you can turn that in if you want
okay thank you does anyone have any
questions
seeing none that we appreciate you
coming and sharing with us today thank
you very much
the chair recognizes Christy Kim
good morning I am here today
representing the National Council for
incarcerated and formerly incarcerated
women and speaking behalf on behalf of
the directly impacted women who are not
able to be here today because of the
snow
in 2017 the women from the National
Council wrote the contents of the
dignity for incarcerated women act in
2019 U.S senators and representatives
reintroduced the ACT which would
highlight the need for improved
conditions for incarcerated women
representative Jaya Paul pointed out
that the ACT among among other things
will ensure that mothers never have to
choose between calling their children or
buying a tampon
accessing sufficient feminine hygiene
products primarily in New Hampshire
jails but also in the women's prison is
a concern as we sit here today
Angelica a currently incarcerated female
noted that during her stay at Belknap
County Jail there were times when she
did not have enough pads and tampons
furthermore she was issued used
underwear which contained blood stains
from other women
Melissa a formerly incarcerated woman
recalls getting only and I quote giant
sized pads that felt like Diapers at
Carroll County Jail she was never
provided with tampons the underwear that
she was issued were stained with urine
and blood during her time at the women's
prison while working in the property
Department she was part of discussions
to recycle underwear and work to sort
through used underwear to find quote the
good ones
Tanya also a formerly incarcerated woman
echoed the reality at Carroll County
Jail stating that she never got tampons
and was subjected to wearing stained
underwear and sleeping on sheets that
were also stained with blood during her
stay at the women's prison she would
occasionally run out of tampons and ask
other women for extras of which lending
and borrowing is a disciplinary offense
Natalie recalls her previous Natalie is
a formerly incarcerated woman as well
she recalls her previous experiences in
Cheshire county jail as this quote you
only get certain amounts of tampons
depending on which officer was working
the unit as a state County resident you
would get used underwear used bras and
used socks the sheets were also old with
stains the federal residents were taken
care of because Liaisons visited once
per month to ensure that they were
getting their needs met at Grafton
County Jail the issue they issued they
also issued underwear that were stained
when I asked for a new pair of underwear
I was told you're lucky you're getting
some because if it were up to me you
would get nothing so I chose not to wear
any my sheets were stained with blood
and I was only ever given pads not
tampons Merrimack County Jail limited
the amount of Tamp tampons you could
have and you had to buy them if you
needed more
at the prison they always gave me stain
sheets and underwear and extra tampons
were hard to get because not every
officer liked you end quote
with only three pairs of issued
underwear per woman and the inconsistent
supply of feminine hygiene products many
of which were oftentimes very expired as
much as three or four years of the pads
that were handed out women are forced to
wash their underwear in the push button
sink because the twice per week laundry
times are not sufficient it's also
important to note that washing your
clothes in the sink and not wearing
underwear are the offenses
we are talking about a basic need that
should be honored in a dignified Manner
and I encourage you to support this
reasonable Bill thank you
no questions thank you oh wait sorry I
got one
um representative salig
products on a broad stroke
um
so would that prevent a prison from
saying we'll give you extra Underpants
that are perhaps have extra liners such
as the ones you know like they make for
teenagers now that are designed to be
period pants
um I I can't speak to exactly what
you're asking um I I think that I can
only tell you that there are certain
rules within the prisons the women are
only given three pairs of underwear they
must prove and show
um the tatteredness of underwear to get
new ones
um in some cases if you have money on
your quote books
um they will not issue extra underwear I
know that this bill is talking about
feminine hygiene products we are going
on the record just talking about the
used underwear just to get it on the
record I know that this bill doesn't
specifically address that I can't really
speak to the language I hope that
answers somewhat of your question thank
you
representative Muse
thank you for taking my question
um
during her introduction uh
representative Reid said there there is
a requirement in New Hampshire that
these products uh be provided but it
sounds like
the current practice may be to provide
access to them so for example your uh
your example of the woman who didn't
have enough who had to buy more the fact
that more are available to be bought
do you see that I mean do you see that
as part of the problem we need to solve
I do see that part of a problem one
because not every woman has money to be
able to purchase more and you can only
purchase more through a union Supply
book which requires a it can take up to
six months for a delivery to come in it
can be as little as a month so you never
really know and you also have to go
through a pretty formal process of
getting money on a slip of paper to the
right people and so you might not get
your order for quite some time it's not
something that you can just purchase on
a commissary which would come in the
following week and I do think that women
shouldn't have to pick between how
they're going to spend what maybe a
dollar a day that they're earning money
on their phones to call home to their
family versus getting a box of tampons
that they need
thank you thank you representative
Newell
um thank you for taking my question
um
my
unfortunately I'm very familiar with
although not in New Hampshire and I'm
horrified to hear that this the way that
that description was given about
Cheshire county my own
um what I was wondering is we have a
couple of different
um a couple of different kind of pieces
of language here that entail different
things right
um similar to what representative Muse
said
um you know we're talking about adequacy
and then we're talking about limits
um and so what I'm wondering is if it's
not based on that person's individual
health needs what is it based on what is
the number based on
yeah that's a great question excuse me I
can say that at the women's prison right
now
um they get a 15 a choice of like 15
regular tampons and 15 Super tampons or
you can choose 30 pads but
um you can't like have unlimited access
I don't know who came up with that
number that's a great question right
everybody's cycle is a bit different and
certainly changes if you have other
conditions such as PCOS
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman um I you know I I
think this is a is a great bill it's
unfortunate that it's necessary
um and and just to address one of the
issues that was raised before about the
type of product that may be necessary
for one woman that was the only
suggestion I would have is adding the
word um inadequate amounts and types as
necessary that would sort of cover
without getting too specific and because
I'm concerned that just leaving it like
this might lead to an inmate having to
say well it says this and they said well
it doesn't tell us that you have to have
tampons as opposed to so if it's just a
more general term I'm just a suggestion
I appreciate that suggestion thank you
representative
after hearing some of the testimony I
almost think that we need to expand on
this bill yeah to because I'm frankly
appalled right that you get three pairs
of underwear and you can't wash them for
every other week or whatever that was
twice per week is the laundry per week
so still yeah not gonna have enough
right so to me that and then you get
gigged if you wash them in the sink yeah
yeah that's
yeah kind of crazy to me but yeah that's
just me so I'm wondering if we need to
include that in this bill that you get
adequate underwear and clean sheets I
mean you would think we wouldn't have to
but apparently we do right
I absolutely agree with you I'm not the
one writing the bill so but I was
certainly yeah I know I appreciate that
though thank you for that comment
that's just me
representative Sue Newman yes thank you
for taking this question you mentioned
that products could be or would be
available for an inmate to purchase and
there were you gave a couple examples of
that do you know if the purchase price
is like reasonable what no we would well
I do sorry I do know it is not
reasonable Union Supply is often
overpriced I don't have the exact prices
in my head but I could imagine it would
be as much as like ten dollars a box for
you know 15 tampons that's thank you
representative Rhodes thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question as
is this something that a visitor is
allowed
to bring no no one is allowed to bring
anything into the prisons or jails okay
okay thank you
give your testimony thank you
the chair recognizes representative Jess
Edwards
uh thank you Mr chair
um I apologize for my uh uniform today I
testified to the on a veterans bill as a
veteran and didn't do a quick change so
so I'm here uh representing Rockingham
District 31 an outstanding District if I
might say so uh and uh I
I am going to testify to something
completely different I'm from the
finance committee
um I've been following
um the the issue on menstrual products
for a while because this issue has been
raised with the school districts
um and I have a bill in because of
following that and so for particularly
for the newer members of the committee
typically when we look at a bill we look
at it from a policy perspective and then
depending on accepting assuming
acceptance of a policy then we look at
it if there's a funding issue this this
bill does not have a fiscal note
and that kind of that concerns me
because
um I I will just State you know for the
record this is a no-brainer from policy
I'm I'd be stunned if this isn't in
practice and I would want to terminate
any leadership in the prison system that
isn't already doing this and complying
with it well uh so the policy is just an
obvious one
um so so that gets us to the money issue
uh Article 28 Alpha says that we shall
not as a legislature issue unfunded
mandates and so
if you look at the words here that we
shall direct the counties to provide
this service because of our Article 28 a
requirement
I think the state has to fund it
and so this is not a fisc there's no
fiscal note attached to this I I tried
to get Mr siani to give me an opinion on
whether or not my concerns about this
were valid and
um and so uh so so that I would just
leave to the committee that I I still
think that there's an open issue here
that assuming this is good policy
um are are we
walking into the obligation of a 28a to
where the state needs to fund that
obligation or that mandate and I'm not
enough of a constitutional lawyer to
answer that but I do think the answer is
probably yes if we tell the counties
they must do it the state must pay for
it and if we let this get out of the
house and send to the Senate without
paying for a new policy that's a mandate
then we are failing to do our job
so that's my testimony thank you
thank you representative
um speaking as the chair if if this bill
is amended in such a way or turns out in
such a way that it does mandate
um it will be sent to fiscal and it will
be run through the procedure to ensure
that it's paid for
um so I I your your concerns are well
met and we will ensure that that is
followed
um thank you Mr chair representative
um say like first
thank you for taking my question thank
you Mr chair um so is it your premise
that tampons and pads are not a
medically necessary product for people
who menstruate
I I don't think I came anywhere near
saying that I would actually I think I
actually am on the record saying exactly
the opposite this is a no-brainer of a
policy and if this isn't being followed
people should be getting fired just to
be clear if you're going to ask
questions of the witness he did testify
that he believes the policy is correct
he's concerned with the fact that if if
it's something new that we're mandating
be done and paid for that we just make
sure it's paid for that was all his
testimony was so do you have a follow-up
based on that and if I may Mr chair I I
I've commanded women in the in the field
in the Hostile fire zone and as a
commander of those women I have ensured
that uh even in a hostile fire zone that
they had the materials that they needed
to remain healthy disease non-battle
injury is the largest way in which we
lose soldiers in combat and so
protecting the force of protecting the
female force is is just something I've
been doing pretty much all my career
I just I just so I just want to
understand
guiding this now who's paying for it if
it's not already included okay so so
this is a technical constitutional
question and one as a representative we
should all be familiar with the New
Hampshire Constitution and our
obligations to adhere to it Article 28
Alpha is very clear that the state shall
not issue a mandate without paying for
the Mandate and so
um so I think this is probably a good
policy I'm just warning the committee
and the chair is already aware of this
apparently that if this mandate to the
counties goes through this is going to
need a fiscal note and it will require
the state to pay for the mandate so I I
will again restate a completely support
this is a policy I just worry about the
money implication and not because we
shouldn't pay it but because we're
obligated to pay it and oftentimes we
fail to do our duty under the
Constitution
representative if you could uh what is
your current um leadership position here
in the State House
uh well I'm I'm in my second term uh as
the chairman of Division III Finance
Finance which is responsible for funding
the Department of Health and Human
Services I I think I was made the chair
of that committee because I have an
entire Adult Career in the healthcare
field and uh in working in all aspects
of it pretty much other than Direct Care
provision because I'm I'm not a provider
and and your testimony today is um in
that role to advise the committee of
what may potentially be a financial
problem that's all is that correct well
yes sir I would just say it's slightly
different for first it's a
constitutional obligation I don't want
to lose the site that we're responding
to our constitutional duties and that
that drives it into a financial issue
representative Bolden
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um I think you're a little late and I'm
concerned that maybe
um some of what you're speaking to was
addressed by the prior speaker so I was
hoping that I could just tell you what
the committee's already heard so that
maybe you could dovetail that into your
commentary on 28a and give us your
additional thoughts
um what we were told earlier is that
um the
Constitution requires
um that
prisoners at the state and county level
receive adequate Health Care
and
County facilities
are already
providing menstrual products largely but
not consistently and that basically the
goal with the wording of the legislation
is to ensure that it is always provided
and sort of cement its place among
the definition of proper health care or
adequate
care in general and so in that regard
it's not a 28-day issue but was I
believe my understanding of the earlier
testimony
um traditionally it would be if we
decide to expand on the underwear and
sheets issue
um oh and that would definitely require
a new experience but I think I don't
think
uh representatives were speaking to that
specifically and so I've just um curious
as far as tampons and pads of facilities
are already providing them and if they
if you really fall under the
Constitutional definition of adequate
Health Care do you still believe that it
could be a 28 day concern to sort of
delineate it more clearly in the law in
this way thank you
uh thank you representative for the
question I am a health care
administrator uh I am not an attorney I
am an Aficionado of the Constitution
this is uh kind of in the detailed weeds
of what the New Hampshire Constitution
specifically would require of us as I
read this legislation it uses the word
necessary adequate amounts as necessary
for uh products and the product
definition is pretty broad product
designed to address menstruation so this
would be the scope of what gets covered
could potentially be pretty broad
given that there's already a
constitutional obligation uh I'll I I
take it your word on on what you've
heard
and if it's not being followed the
prisoners have an opportunity to file a
civil suit for having their
constitutional rights violated but I
would also think I'd leave it to the
committee but the LBA will conduct
audits so so the allegations of of
negligence a managerial and
administrative negligence that I've
heard just here is are severe and I
would want the state the executive
branch to follow up to see the extent to
which the counties are violating those
constitutional rights that you mentioned
hello
last one
thank you
um
so um you mentioned that the bill
includes terminology such as necessary
and adequate is my understanding that
that's also in the constitute the
section of the Constitution that speaks
to health care for um the incarcerated
that it be necessary and adequate
um
I guess my question is do you do you
think it would be less expensive for the
taxpayers to pay for a civil suit loss
or tampons
I I I'm I'm not going to answer that
question because I I think that will
obfuscate my point my my point is if
we're issuing a mandate from the state
to the counties uh and it's a new
mandate then uh we certainly are
obligated to pay for it and I was just
suggesting that uh given the severity of
the abuse that I've heard uh we may want
to supplement that with uh an LBA audit
or ask the executive branch to conduct
an investigation because I think that's
just cruel I would even go as far to say
that it would be cruel and unusual
punishment to deny a woman or basic
health care needs
thank you representative
thanks
no ask him after
um at this point I would like to call
um Jane Graham from the Department of
Corrections
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee thank you for allowing me
to testify today
um I would like to testify well actually
I should add that commissioner Hanks is
on her way she was she sent me here
first uh in case she wasn't able to make
it but she is on her way so if you have
more questions that I'm unable to answer
she can absolutely answer them
thank you for allowing me to speak
regarding hb421 the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections supports this
legislation
um it's a we currently provide menstrual
products to women who are in our
facilities we currently have 136 women
between our New Hampshire correctional
facility for women and Shea Farm
transitional housing unit
we provide
um we do I want to speak a little bit to
the 15 limit we do initially give 15
products to women but there is the
flexibility to ask for more if you need
them so we don't have an actual limit as
to how many that we will provide it's
unlimited we provide
um two types of maxi pads a panty
Shields product and two types of tampons
to women if
you've heard people talk about
purchasing we do allow people to
purchase if we the products that we
offer aren't what individuals are
looking for providing feminine hygiene
products to our residents is the right
thing to do for the health and safety of
the women that we support
um and it's something that we're we're
proud to do to help support the women
that we we house I want to thank you for
your time today and I will take any
questions that you have
thank you what is the Department's
policy regarding underwear for uh for
for women they're issued three pairs we
a brand new underwear when at the prison
now I I can only speak to the prison I
can't speak to the county jails at all I
don't have any awareness of those
situations I like others have said
anecdotal
um but I don't I don't follow their
policies at all
um
so three pairs of brand new underwear
when they arrive
um we laundry service is at least two
times a week and it's sometimes more
than that so that's our policy
in sheets if sheets are stained and
unable to be cleaned if they're staying
and unable to be cleaned then we would
dispose of those
thank you
and if an inmate
runs short of products
um
do you provide more as no we do not we
do not limit we only limit the amount
they're able to have at one time
um so that but that was not an overall
limit
finally for my questions if this law
were magically signed this afternoon by
the governor would it cost the
department any more money not at this
time it it wouldn't because we are it's
something we already do again if there
were additions to it indeed but if we
were amended to underwear and this
wouldn't cost another dime correct thank
you representative Newell
thank you chairman Roy and thank you for
taking my question absolutely
commissioner Hanks can probably answer
questions even better than I can so
she definitely can
it's afternoon good afternoon honorable
members of the committee my name is
Helen Hicks I'm the commissioner of the
Department of Corrections and happy to
assist with any questions on this matter
sure
um my question is you know it seems like
this is policy this is in the
Constitution it sounds like you guys
um as far as the Department of
Corrections and and we're you know
taking counties out of this are um
handling this very well and um you know
as far as the the letter of the law this
is the policy and and it should be
provided for so I guess my my thoughts
go to why is it not actually being
implemented in these type of situations
and I know that these may be you know
anecdotal and things like that but
um so you know I guess what it really
comes down to is accountability for
people who don't abide by the policy and
you know is there any way that you could
speak to that or if there have been
incidents of that and you know how is
that handled
thank you for that uh question I can
only speak to the State Department of
Corrections so they don't oversee County
jails
um and I I certainly know from the
collaboration pre
um this proposed bill that I've heard
things that happen at County jails you
know and assure you the department
provides for this service provides for
it freely and then even augments by
allowing people to purchase more or
different varieties that they might want
in addition to just want to reaffirm we
give brand new undergarments to people
coming to our facilities we do not
recycle undergarments for men or women
for that matter
and you know from a perspective of
since it's not in the law at this point
there's no level in which you could go
from municipal or County to county and
say are you complying with the law
and that's all I can offer I mean it's
it's a well-made point
um but I think the other value that
might be considered is the American
Corrections Association has standards
for jails and standards for prisons so
striving to hit those standards would be
applicable here
you're welcome
representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
so before everybody starts
throwing horrible darts looks at me I I
do understand that
that there is I don't know that I don't
know the official name of it there's
that some kind of a shock that that
females can experience with a tampon
so thank you okay and so it's kind of a
two-part one could that could that be
considered dangerous and in a facility
and there's a lot of talk of the wording
in this is actually kind of vague for
how deep we got into these weeds so if
this were to be amended do you think
that it should actually say
you know hygiene hygiene products of
their choosing
representative Rhodes I think that's a
fair um concern I would say since we're
talking about the incarceration of adult
females by that time in their life they
know what product works best for them so
allowing them to make the choice that is
appropriate to their experience makes a
lot of sense as an aside if that
happened in our institutions we have the
immediate First Responders to come and
assist as well and health care in
general so if they were experiencing
something else on toward we would be
able to assist
thank you Mr chairman so just to clarify
that
the wording of their choosing you
actually think would
because doesn't say that that's not what
it says so like I said we kind of got
into the to the weeds here pretty good
of what it doesn't say uh so I just
wanted to clarify that you think that
that might actually be more clear if
it's of their choosing instead of just
saying hey we gave you pads and here you
go you have your supply yeah I do think
it's okay I do think it's important to
give a menstruating uh person the
opportunity to pick what works best okay
thank you if I may clarify that
of their choosing between a pad and a
tampon not brand names
the generalities of the you know
Q-tip versus yeah I just know there's a
lot of different products and different
prices and it would be impossible sir
that I just learned about that I didn't
even know
I'm leaving it Broad
and a general is important so that we
can respond at least from State
Corrections and many of my other County
Jail superintendents do the same things
as state corrections so please I don't
want people walking away thinking the
county jail superintendents are not all
doing this many do
thank you uh representative scitec I
think the word of their reasonable
choosing would take care of all of that
but I want to I'd like to make a comment
which I think you'll understand I've
been around this place for a while it's
unusual to see a commissioner before you
you see their second in command and I
appreciate the fact that the
commissioner has come here thank you
representative scitec
I appreciate you for that representative
Bolden
thank you Mr chairman a lot thanks for
taking my question
um commissioner Hanks I was hoping the
bike could be a little closer to you
when you're speaking
um but my question is would you be
willing for the education of the
committee in general
um because we do have a lot of new folks
this year to explain the differences
between the state facility and the
various County facilities because we
heard testimony earlier about for
example Belknap was mentioned and it
might be helpful to understand whether
or not that facility is under your
control and some of the experiences that
people in Belknap have had and your
relationship to that if any and also
um
in explaining that could you explain to
us how you believe this legislation
would impact your budget versus how you
suspect that this legislation might
impact the county budget and I know that
that might be a little challenging but
just a primer on the difference between
County state would be cool thank you if
you could just say what's under your
control and and no speculation about the
counties please thank you very
appropriate thank you chairman Roy and
thank you representative Bolden for that
question probably because I haven't also
had any water today yet
um simply stated the county jails are
not under the purview of the State
Department of Corrections if you're
sentenced to County Jail you've received
a sentence of one year or less for a
misdemeanor crime and or you're in
pre-tile pretrial detention pending
sentencing on a charge if you are at the
State Department of Corrections you have
been sentenced to a felony level one
year or more I balance all this there's
this thing called pre-trial credit so
you may come to us with one year or more
but you may have pre-trial credit that
gives you six months it's with us that's
really simply stated the difference
between the two
[Music]
representative Bolden there was a second
part to your question
thank you for that that it will not cost
the Department of Corrections any
additional money and I could not intend
to speculate on the cost to the county
jails because I don't know all of their
varying practices and I defer that to
them and I asked this before you came in
the room I'll I'll ask it again if if
this law were to be amended and signed
this afternoon
that mandated that you provided as
requested whatever necessary products
they need and mandated clean and new
underwear and mandated clean sheets if
they are unable to be laundered properly
would that cost you another penny
no no end
that is good to know thank you
representative Newman
I didn't have a question but now I have
one because I didn't think we sheets
were discussed here but anyway it could
be um for women's undergarments when
they actually submit them to be
laundered
are they identified and returned to the
individual
because some of the testimonies seem to
be contrary to that
thank you for that question
representative Newman all of the
individuals property is labeled with
their last name and they receive a
specific unique number that is written
both in permanent marker but they're
also labeled so they at the State
Department of Corrections their laundry
is done at a minimum twice a week and
that's in addition to their base set
that we provide to them for free and
then they have the ability to purchase
more through the specific vendors
just follow up yes sir and does does
that include garments as well as the
sheets uh are they issued sheets as
their property
they are issued sheets as their property
um and they are numbered
it is not perfect sometimes they do end
up with the wrong person but the goal is
that your things go in a laundry bag to
the laundry that you're in charge of and
it comes back from the laundry in that
bag drive for you to take care of thank
you you're welcome
representative scitec
um of the chair uh we're preaching to
the choir here the real issue is with
the counties I mean we've always not
wasted our time but uh we need somebody
from the county there is an association
of counties there that seem to be the
people most affected we haven't heard
from them so I'm sort of slightly put
out I guess I would um
hesitate to concur but if I were the
type to concur I would concur
um
any further questions to the
commissioner oh representative State
League
the question I'm just
I'm just if we get more specific about
the types of hygiene products and
Preferred Product style are there any
products which you at the person level
would say are not appropriate to be
provided
um to you know in terms of feminine
hygiene for example you know I know many
teenagers use period pants right like
specific Underpants for that or people
who believe in sustainable
sustainability uh might use Diva cups um
which for those of you who don't
menstruate are silicone and other
material cups that are inserted and
capture menstrual fluid and then are
removed cleaned and replaced
representative selig and please new
members if I pronounce your last name
incorrectly please let me know how to
pronounce it correctly that was perfect
thank you
um I'm glad you brought that up because
um the second item was one I've only
recently become familiar with and we
would not prefer a vessel that allows
for the storage of blood in a
correctional facility because it is uh
can be a bloodborne pathogen as well as
used as a weapon to assault our
employees with what I would prefer and
recommend if we could stick to menstrual
pads and
is tampon the right word I don't know if
that's generic enough those are the two
primary products pads is generalized
enough that it allows us which we do
provide different heavy medium light and
thin so on and so forth same on the
tampons
and the menstrual underwear we do not
provide menstrual underwear
that I I think we provide enough
feminine products if I could as an aside
unique to the Department of Corrections
possibly we also have what are called
resident communication committees where
myself I go quarterly and sit with
residents who are selected among their
peers at all the sites to bring up
topics of concern at the State
Department of Corrections with the
individuals and cars incarcerated at the
New Hampshire correctional facility for
women this has never come up in six
years
and I suspect even further than that
again it's not an issue for the
department but I appreciate the
carefulness of your question
as an aside you're talking about other
property when you're talking about
sheets and things like that we have a
robust property policy I would ask I
would ask politely if we could stick to
feminine products in this bill and if
you were going to look at other property
that's provided at the start of
incarceration and during incarceration
that's a much larger topic of discussion
thank you and that is certainly
understood however the testimony we
heard regarding underwear was very
troubling so it'd be very difficult for
us to walk away without at least
examining that a little bit further
um any other questions of the
commissioner oh representative Muse
just a quick question if if we don't
change this law could a future
commissioner roll back some of the the
policies that you have that are
currently uh best practice
representative Muse that's a fair
question but this policies existed even
before me
um nationally in Corrections this is
what you do
absent the law or with the law
there being no further questions thank
you very much for coming again
thank you and um is there anyone else
wishing to testify who is not what who
go ahead
I promise not to ask any more questions
while the commissioner's sitting there
um I recall
maybe in Prior years
that you spoke to receiving in prisoners
from County who had long-standing
medical issues that hadn't been
addressed in their County facility and
that the responsibility for addressing
them fell to you because they would be
in your care for so long and because you
have these enhanced policies for care
prisoners and I was just curious if
you've ever received or like maybe had
conversations with prisoners who were in
County facilities who reported
um to you something related to
menstruation that they experienced in
county that didn't satisfy your state
level policy on the matter
if you could answer that without
specifically getting into County names
that would be appreciated happy to do
that representative Bolden that's not
been something someone shared upon
admission the history you recall I think
being more poignant we received somebody
with for example a broken arm from a
facility that had not been mended but
not on the menstruation topic
you're welcome
thank you for your testimony
um I will be appointing a subcommittee
on this and the subcommittee will be
representative Rhodes representative
saley representative Newell
representative Bolin representative
Murphy representative Rhodes will be the
chair
representative Pruitt wanted to be on it
but I didn't think it would be a good
idea
and with that the public hearing on HB
what was that
14 41 is closed and we'll be in recess
until one o'clock is that right
1 30.
130.
can I swapped up committees
foreign
at this time we will be opening the
public hearing on hb216
and the chair will recognize
Representatives Santa nastazo to
introduce his bill
thank you chairman and members of the
criminal justice committee
I'm here today to rep to introduce House
Bill 216 to exempt die
methotryptamine from the controlled Drug
Act
all right so uh Consciousness is a
strange phenomenon it can't be explained
it's kind of hard to think about we
actually don't even know how to define
it
um dmt's substance that may be a link
between the physical world and the
spiritual world so dimethyltryptamine
commonly known as DMT is a naturally
occurring psychedelic substance that's
been used for centuries and traditional
spiritual practice DMT can be smoked or
Vaped can be ingested as T in the form
of Ayahuasca DMT is speculated to exist
in all animal and plant life but it's
known to exist in uh hundreds and
thousands known thousands of plant and
animal species and it's also in the
human body
uh believed to be produced in the penal
gland of the brain so this molecular
compound is extremely common on Earth
and no one actually
knows why it exists or what its function
is in plants and animals because we just
have no research on it so uh according
to the National survey on drug use and
health less than one percent of
Americans age 12 and old are reported
using DMT at least once in their
lifetime
so DMT is just not abused
all right and uh I have a lot of
testimony here on actually the effects
of DMT but I'm going to defer that to
Derek who's uh actual expert
um so I'll just talk about freedom to
practice religion so uh in 2006 there
was a Supreme Court case where U.S
custom agents seized over uh 30 gallons
of Ayahuasca that was being shipped to a
church in New Mexico and the Supreme
Court unanimously delivered judgment in
favor of the church under the 1993
religious freedom restoration act uh
chief justice Roberts held that the
government had not adequately
demonstrated had a compelling interest
in Banning what even Federal prosecutors
admit is a sincere religious practice
and uh so there's just churches uh using
DMT and Ayahuasca and ceremonies
becoming uh rapidly mainstream in the
United States and Canada so any
restriction on the substance when
intended to be used in a religious
practice is a violation of Article 5 of
the New Hampshire Constitution where
every individual has a natural and
unannual right to worship God according
to the dictates of his own conscious and
reason and no subject shall be hurt
molested or restrained in his person
Liberty or estate for worshiping God in
the manner in season most agreeable to
the dictates of his own conscious or for
his religious profession sentiments or
persuasion provided he does not disturb
the public peace or disturb others in
their religious warship
um so uh any questions I would actually
like you guys as far as what DMT does
and how it works I'd like you did it
defer to Derek he's talked to lots of uh
phds and people that I know this topic
and has uh extensive experience with it
um but I will take any other questions
um
could
um regarding the religions
I'm a Catholic and I must have missed
that memo from the pope but is there can
you tell me the religions I do actually
um use this as part of their common
practice if you know uh so there's uh
South American and uh Amazon Amazon
areas the Shaman's there have used it
for centuries uh so that practice has
been sort of coming uh to the West
thank you
representative Muse
how would you actually uh obtain uh this
chemical now
well uh it exists in most plant life if
not all and I think the most there's it
can be synthesized artificially
uh but I think most people actually get
it from a root bark that's imported from
Brazil and they somehow mix it with some
stuff and extract the actual DMT
chemical
foreign
so is it a is it a commercially
available uh available drug or is it
sort of a make it yourself in your
kitchen kind of a drug
so the root bark itself is is legal as
lots of plants are legal you can go
outside and pick some maple leaves and
that's legal uh
but yeah then someone has to actually
uh do something with the plant to get
the DMT extracted out of it when the
when the DMT is extracted out in its in
its purest form at that moment it's a
controlled drug
representative scitec
you've missed two critical ingredients
do you get high from this stuff and is
is it addictive yeah so I left I had
written testimony on this and I wanted
to skip it for Derek uh but is not
addictive and uh you'd have to Define
getting high on it
for me to answer that what does that
mean
um let me take a stab at it would it
interfere with your operation of Motor
Vehicle
I would definitely not want to operate
more vehicle uh under influence of this
drug
thank you any other questions
representative Murphy
chairman thank you for taking
me for what purposes would
uh like I was saying that kind of
question would be much better answered
by Derek uh but uh DMT gives us insight
into our own Consciousness uh it can
take it takes people their testimony of
people that have taken this uh this
substance is really bizarre but they go
and they go to another uh world as they
see it and I mean uh it has a reputation
for being known as the god molecule
because it actually will convert in
atheists into religious believers
representative saley thank you so I just
want to clarify so it's essentially a
hallucinogenic in its properties is that
correct uh I would agree so
thank you representative thank you
at this time the chair would recognize
uh Derek show Joe zazewski
I apologize for that
thank you good afternoon
um my name is Derek janazewski I am the
founding pastor
for pachamama Sanctuary we are an
Ayahuasca church here in New Hampshire
we've been operating since uh the end of
2019 I'm sorry the beginning of 2019 in
February we opened up
Ayahuasca is a plant medicine it's a tea
it's generated by making tea with a leaf
from a shakuna plant and a vine called
ayahuasca
uh shakuna is c h
a c r u n a chakruna and Ayahuasca I
think you have the spelling on that
Ayahuasca is the vine Ayahuasca doesn't
have
it has very very little DMT in it or
dimethyltryptamine the
dimethyltryptamine comes from the
chicuna leaf and it's boiled together
like tea and drunk like tea there's no
um there's no processing that's gone on
there's no chemicals that go into it and
this Ayahuasca is can is uh is worshiped
in South America as a medicine and it's
a medicine for the soul
um it's a beautiful beautiful teacher
and it connects us with another level of
Consciousness things that we hide from
ourselves
so what it allows us to do is go inside
of our mind most drugs like alcohol
cocaine and opiates they're abused so
that people can forget or stop feeling
something
what Ayahuasca does with DMT is it
allows people to feel those things
and instead of running away from them
and it's an uncomfortable process it
doesn't feel good it's not a happy
enjoyable experience
um but when we take our ego away and we
can start to feel those feelings with
dimethyltryptamine with Ayahuasca
um it allows us to get closer to God
because our separation is not with God
it's with ourselves
and so this molecule this beautiful
molecule allows us to connect deeply
with our inner spirit and reconnect with
God
it's my Sacrament and I wouldn't be
alive without it
um I've have about 2 000 members of my
church at this point two thousand
members of my church and I've had dozens
dozens of men and women who have come
some of them were addicts some of them
were veterans that gave a lot to this
country some of them are soccer moms
that were sexually abused and they've
come to me and told me that they were
suicidal before coming they were going
to kill themselves if it didn't work and
they now have beautiful lives almost all
of them I'm in contact with them all the
time at least once every couple of
months we exchange emails I have zoom
calls where they come
um this molecule is present in almost
every single living thing almost every
animal on the planet has this in it
um and it has something to do with the
connection of Consciousness uh the
molecule itself looks almost identical
to serotonin but right now all of you
have DMT in your body currently at this
moment right now we all do right
serotonin is a feel-good chemical
DMT or dimethyltryptamine has almost
exactly the same makeup so it attaches
to the same exact receptors
um it's just in a different way
uh it's very very safe it's it's not
abusable nobody wants to take this stuff
all the time it's a very intense
experience and having that much energy
and that much presence of a spiritual
experience it's something that somebody
might want to do once a year
um it's nothing that would make somebody
want to steal their neighbor's car or a
catalytic converter to get more of it
it's not like that it's it's it's it's
never going to be like that
um it's an experience with God and
that's scary
an experience with love that's a really
scary thing
um it's self-love it teaches people to
love themselves again
that's what serotonin helps us do too
it rebalances a lot of the brain
chemicals like oxytocin melatonin
serotonin
cortisol especially
um so after an experience with
dimethyltryptamine people's cortisol
levels drop significantly it gives them
sometimes a few days sometimes a few
weeks of a level mind it relieves the
symptoms of depression
um and I would say that it does have
medicinal value for sure
it's being studied right now at Johns
Hopkins very very deeply in the form of
um psilocybin because psilocybin breaks
down to DMT
psilocybin turns into solosin and then
when it gets in the bloodstream and Adam
pops off and it becomes DMT it's the
same molecule it's the same molecule
um
religions around this have been around
for thousands of years as best we can
tell
there's two that came from South America
that are presently operating in the
country both have had uh unanimous
decisions from the U.S Supreme Court 9-0
both times and that's Santo dime and the
udv these are both Brazilian churches
that came here and they're operating
here uh above board with exemptions from
the DEA
the DEA has paid me a visit
and we talked about it and um they're
not gonna they're not gonna prosecute me
um it's the first amendment protects me
um but that protects me there's other
people out there that don't want to come
to a retreat at my place or don't want
to feel religious
they deserve to explore their own mind I
think that's my view
um
kind of talk for a lot so if anybody has
any questions I'd love to answer them
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um given the the um effects that you've
described why would you what's your
opinion as to why the medical community
isn't using this or hasn't been using
this since it's well known
um why are they not using it to treat
the depression is it given our mental
health uh crisis that we're all saying
why would you think that if it has all
those benefits that it's not being used
by the medical community to address to
help address those
so that's a that's a great question
um and I have some opinions that I'll
keep to myself but they're currently
studying it right now in a lot of
universities across the country like I
like I mentioned Johns Hopkins they're
studying this deeply
um and my view is is that psilocybin is
a lot more
um well known but DMT is being studied
it's being studied a lot right now this
new psychedelic Renaissance is brought
on
uh an incredible amount of study
it takes a while for that to come and uh
be utilized
it's free correct
yes
representative Muse
do you have any medical expertise uh in
in terms of the impact or potential
impact of of a drug like this
um on somebody who who not only has a
mental health issue but who may also
have a form of chemical dependency so
for instance
taking DMT with with alcohol or taking
it with an antidepressant or taking it
with another type of drug which is very
common among people who abuse drugs they
abuse multiple drugs do you have any
knowledge of the potential interaction
the DMT might have if someone like that
used it
I do
so the interactions with most other
drugs are safe
however
due to the fact that DMT is almost a
carbon copy of Serotonin if somebody is
taking an antidepressant like Celexa
Alexa Lexapro
Wellbutrin things of that nature the
ssris
well then you can have a flood of
Serotonin and that person can go into
something called serotonin syndrome the
serotonin syndrome is an awful
experience
um it's it's very very rarely fatal
um but it's really an uncomfortable
experience
um it's a raised uh raised heart rate
raised blood pressure and uh lowered
respiration rate or raised restoration
rate well since their serotonin
regulates all those things the
respiration rate the blood pressure and
the um and the heart rate uh serotonin
syndrome makes them all kind of go
Haywire you know I have been around no
less than 5 000 people that have taken
this and I would say
maybe a hundred people have been
dishonest about their use of
um of uh antidepressants that's really
the main one
um and of those hundred I had four
people that had a difficult experience
and no medical emergencies I've spoken
with uh
neuroscientists from Harvard about this
and multiple doctors nurses and EMTs to
make sure that the safety of this is
incredibly important and
um theoretically it can it can be fatal
if combined with uh with um
an antidepressant but there isn't a case
that we can find
um the the lethalia this is is almost
zero
as far as I know there's there's been no
cases in the United States that DMT has
caused uh death
um I have a question if
as you know with opioids there there's a
Narcan is there something that can can
bring someone out of one of these
experiences if they're having a an issue
uh yes lemon lemon and salt
it it pretty much neutralizes the the
molecule and makes it Blow apart it's
it's a natural remedy to a natural
molecule
lemon and salt
mm-hmm
um I I looked into this in advance and
was trying to find some studies I'm glad
to hear that there are some that are in
process now so I can kind of follow up
on those ones I'm curious with your
experience vast experience
um what is your process since this you
know kind of hasn't gone through the
study process and isn't currently being
used medically professionally as as far
as I'm aware what is the process that
you've come to find is
um the right way I mean the amount uh
questions you need to ask in advance the
process for intake essentially of
someone who who is coming to you and
wants to experience that yeah
um so for me what I have is a medical
form I have them sit with a nurse to go
over their medical form when they come
um and I have a conversation with them
ahead of time I've got warnings all over
the place and and all of that
um but I I don't want to I don't want to
distract from the fact that
um my use of it is religious
the state of New Hampshire isn't all
going to come to my church
right I I appreciate this bill because
it's going to help me be a little bit
more safe in my practice because I mean
let's be honest what I'm doing is not
currently totally legal you know and I
understand that there might be some
repercussions of that I believe in my
Sacrament so much I'm willing to risk
that but there's other people in New
Hampshire other than me and people in my
church and they should be able to
explore their Consciousness they're not
going to have a medical form
um just to clarify the reason I'm asking
that question is you know the bill is
very straightforward right the bill says
we're going to exempt this from the
control Drug Act so that means that it I
mean that would uh if I'm correct that
would make it completely legal for
anyone to use not through a medical
professional or within the context of
religion
um or something like that and so uh what
I'm what I'm trying to get at is kind of
the safety precautions that that you
need to take and kind of how if it were
legalized
um kind of how would we ensure that
other people are able to take those
precautions as well does that make sense
yeah I understand I understand I
understand where you're going for where
you're coming from and um
I don't think that any of those are
necessary
I don't believe that those safety
precautions are necessary
um with something like dimethotryptamine
that that I can't find a single case of
a death uh cigarettes cause 440 000
deaths a year in this country
um
the uh you know
um I I do it because I want to make
people become feel safe because it is a
scary process what we do
this is a little bit different than what
people will be experiencing on the
street
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chairman thank you Derek for your
testimony I wondering what is the
typical ceremony like at your church uh
you mentioned just now that it was a
little bit more scary than it would be
like on the street what what does it
look like you said you had 5 000
experiences that you had witnessed so uh
right so we have uh an indigenous Shaman
come to our church
from Colombia Peru Brazil
and Ayahuasca when you take Ayahuasca it
is a six hour very deep journey into
traumas and
um emotions that we've been hiding from
right uh when you vaporize it and smoke
it you kind of go to another world and
you come back in about 10 minutes
creates a very short and Powerful
experience
where the way that most people are going
to take it at home uh when you come to
our Sanctuary ours is a long process
when you drink Ayahuasca tea it's
between four and six hours sometimes
eight and ten but usually between four
and six hours
um and it's you're very vulnerable for a
long period of time
so we have a staff of about 10 people to
make sure that you're very cared for
that you're safe that you're comfortable
a nurse on staff and all that
and so it's it's scary being vulnerable
and scary feeling feelings sometimes
foreign
Murphy
thank you and thank you for taking my
question when you talk about your staff
what what are the qualifications of the
staff
um we have I have various different
staff members for various different
things uh you know you don't need a PhD
to wash buckets
um so we have uh we have people all up
and down the scale but I have a PhD in
Psychology on staff I have multiple
people that are trained in integration
coaching in addiction recovery uh
licensed addiction recovery
um
I forget I forget what the term is but
there there uh then I have uh somebody
who has uh who worked in nursing and EMT
on staff and then multiple other people
who have trained in Peru and Brazil
that'll work with this medicine closely
with shamans for for a long period of
time in addition to that we have people
that like help people back and forth to
the bathroom and don't have a very
important
um you know body of knowledge
mm-hmm
representative wheeler thank you
when was dimethyltryptamine made illegal
do you know
thank you for your testimony
this time the chair calls Ian Freeman
okay thank you uh good afternoon thank
you for uh considering this important
bill I wanted to bring you up to speed I
don't want to repeat what was already
said because it was really good
information I'm also a minister with the
Shire Free Church I have some personal
experience with using DMT for Spiritual
reasons
and there was a very important Supreme
Court decision there were a few National
Supreme Court decisions that were
mentioned here so far but I want to
bring your attention to a New Hampshire
Supreme Court decision it came out in
December of 2020 it was a unanimous
decision in the case of a gentleman who
had been arrested for psilocybin which
is as you heard a related molecule
and he was convicted at the Superior
Court appealed his case and explained to
the court the Supreme Court that this
was his religious Sacrament
and they said that the New Hampshire
Constitution
absolutely protects not just your right
to religion which the U.S Constitution
protects but the New Hampshire
Constitution goes so far as to protect
your right to worship
in the way that you choose and so with a
full unanimous vote they overturned the
superior Court's conviction of this
gentleman and set him free
so this bill would simply catch up to
where the courts have already set forth
the courts have already said that the
use of psychedelic
substances is legal in New Hampshire for
Spiritual reasons
but yet someone who is not using it for
a spiritual reason or at least that's
perhaps not their intention they may end
up deciding that it was a spiritual
experience but if they were just using
it for a recreational purpose I don't
think that person needs to go to prison
they don't need to go to jail simply
because their intentions with this
molecule were different so again this
bill would simply catch up legislatively
to where we already are in the New
Hampshire courts that's all I had
if you have any questions happy to take
them
representative
thank you for taking my question sure
you just mentioned another substance
that the Supreme Court said in New
Hampshire Supreme Court said was legal
based on the New Hampshire Constitution
after that ruling was that removed from
the controlled drug list or is it still
on the list right unfortunately been on
the list oh yes it's absolutely on that
uh that list unfortunately last year
there was a bill that would have
decriminalized uh psilocybin mushrooms
and it I don't think it made it out of
committee unfortunately as far as it was
not given an
OTP it should have been because again
this would that bill and this one would
have caught up legislatively to where
this courts already are but usually the
legislature as you know takes a long
time to uh to get anything done that
should be done
I didn't know that but thank you okay
now you know
I represent him no
real quick
um I am not fully caught up in my email
I think I'm about 24 hours behind have
you submitted that uh the Supreme Court
ruling the briefing because I think that
would be really helpful uh no I haven't
but I'm happy to do that right
all right sure
thank you for your testimony sure thing
the chair recognizes Joshua Holmes
hello and thank you for being here to
hear this testimony today
um I had the Good Fortune to go to
college on the GI Bill and so the
government paid for me to read books for
four years and one of those books was
the Epic of Gilgamesh which is the
oldest version of the hero's journey
that we have in surviving texts
something like five or six thousand
years old and in that story the hero of
the story goes through the flood of the
Bible but from a different perspective
and he utilizes uh the drug that is
Ayahuasca or DMT to Journey to the
spirit world and uh to resolve the
personal issues that had made him a
Tyrant King and allowed him to be a
complete person and to rule his kingdom
with Justice
um
this same chemical is found in the
acacia Bush which is the burning bush
that we know from the Bible that Moses
saw that allowed him to speak to God so
it is general knowledge that the purpose
of this drug is to allow you to achieve
a religious experience
I just wanted to make that clear that's
something that I got out of my undergrad
degree if anybody has any questions
about these stories I don't know
anything about using the drug personally
but I could tell you about the meaning
behind the stories I got the degree in
it
there being no questions thank you all
right thank you for sharing your time
the chair recognizes I believe it's
Reverend Gabe lay Holden Holden
yeah Reverend gabley holdren
so
there's an incredible amount of medical
utility to this substance
to put it in recognizable terms it's
it's dreams it literally exists in the
pineal gland it's released in small
quantities during dreams large
quantities near during near-death
experiences
uh
you're making something illegal that you
are all currently carrying around inside
the middle of your head
that's absurd
and there are a lot of people who
bring their lives back together because
they have some of this it
has tremendous effects on PTSD and we
have a lot of veterans that could really
use a bit more sanity
um
it's incredibly effective at treating
Other Drug addictions especially the the
Opium epidemic that we have now could be
drastically improved from it
um
I don't know which is more absurd the
fact that oh oh by the way it's in all
your groceries like we'd have to put
away every grocery store owner if we're
going to actually enforce this it's
absurd
the whole the thing about this molecule
it uh gets digested incredibly easy
that's why you have to do this specialty
to get you to not digest the thing
it's in everything it's in everything
that's alive
um I'm happy to take any questions
I I did have one question you know given
oh sorry uh one more thing I wanted to
do uh uh the uh illegalization as I
understand it it was uh uh
uh in a swath of uh when LSD was put uh
uh put on the uh on the drug list to um
they'd seen this massive social change
they're like clamped down on that what
are they doing LSD put that in there
what's this that's also uh one of these
uh okay put those all on the on the list
uh as I understand that's that was the
only real thinking on this thing in the
first place sorry
sure
um
and the fact that it it seems like
um the drug is manufactured
um maybe not by the people who use it
but manufactured locally for the for the
people who do who do use it
um
one of the things that I'm I'm curious
about is
people like people who have addiction
issues mental health issues PTSD issues
taking a a powerful drug that
if you're taking the wrong
antidepressant has the risk of actually
killing you
outside of a clinical setting
um
what is your ability to actually help
people who get into not just mental
distress but actual physical distress
in your places of worship
what do you mean physical distress
one of the things we heard earlier was
there there actually is a risk of death
due to a serotonin yeah it's uh you can
overdose on it like very many substances
I mean enough water will kill you and
that's the thing uh the the way that
it's made uh there are two substances
one uh it has a heavy dose of this thing
that's in everything and the other uh
gets your body to not digest it so uh
the the drugs that you're referring to
are this side of it so you're just
overdosing on it so it's like oh don't
uh don't take a bunch of alcohol when
you've been taking a bunch of alcohol
yeah the difference between dosage
between poison and medicine is always in
the dosage
I'm not sure you answered my question
I'm sorry oh uh what what how do how do
you how are you prepared to actually
take care of people who may have an
adverse physical reaction uh to the
chemical
oh
um well uh I I don't run a church uh for
this
um I I I will vouch for uh everything
that's been said on that but
um so personally if I was going to and I
I suspect that he probably has this uh
there are ways of diluting that effect
uh there are things you can take uh the
first thing I would be like okay get
them some water but like I'm I'm sure he
knows the chemistry far better than I do
to uh tone this down
so it would be yeah absolutely if you're
going to run a business or a church that
does this it would be prudent to have
some on hand
but
any anything that you have too much of
is going to kill people and the thing
with this is because it's illegal it's
not dosed out
like it doesn't come in nice little
here's your dosage because it hasn't
been able to be put on shelves so we
don't have this in its proper dosage
foreign
to aspirin if you take a bunch of
aspirin
yeah you'll you'll it'll be a blood
thinner and if you're already on blood
thinners then that can kill you
representative wheeler
has this ever killed anyone
I don't know
thank you for your testimony today
chair recognizes Jason Gerhard
foreign
thank you chairman thank you members of
the committee for hearing this bill
my name is Jason Gerhard I represent
Northfield Franklin Mayor Mike 25.
and I'll keep this short
we obviously are in the throes of a
major opioid addiction
epidemic and the current
so let's put it this way a large
proportion of people who are
incarcerated suffer from addiction
issues that should be kind of
self-evident the way of treating this is
by giving them other drugs so most
namely Suboxone now Suboxone
is an opioid blocker the problem is you
can get high off of Suboxone
so
it's it's just a mess it seems like
we're substituting one thing for another
thing when we when we go into the
Psychedelic Realm
people are taking this drug once
and overcoming their addictions or at
least coming to con to confront the
issues that drive them to their
addictions which I think is key
we're looking at the dangers of this as
if it's somebody doing it every weekend
which just doesn't happen it's like
psilocybin with mushrooms you know it's
just not something that people do like
that or if they do they're just burnt
out and they're going to be the same
people huffing paint I mean what are you
gonna do band paint so my point being is
that if we really want to deal with the
the addiction issues we have to kind of
look to something that's actually been
used in the past to cure them
Nate just real quick Aldous Huxley back
in the 1950s he wrote doors of
perception that's actually where the
band The Doors got their name from but
in it he was talking about his masculine
experience and other psychedelics and
shortly thereafter they banned all that
and canceled all the research so we've
kind of been in the Dark Ages
of a lot of this stuff so at the very
least if you guys do just decide to itl
this or whatever at least at least in
the future or somehow amend this somehow
at least open up some kind of ability to
investigate and start some trials at the
state level so we can actually see
what's really going on here we have
plenty of people locked up why not you
know I mean let's just try to figure out
we got to do something because locking
people app's not working we're gonna
make stuff more illegal I mean it's
already legal so it's like so anyway I'd
be glad to take some questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you very much
chair recognizes uh Mr Frank Staples
thank you
uh I'm gonna try to touch on a few
things and I will credential myself
um I spent
five years in solitary confinement two
and a half years for refusing to shave
my beard on religious grounds so I do
understand
um
the First Amendment and what is it the
what this gentleman should be referring
to is not the first amendment because
it's less protective than
um
hours Article 5 is religious freedom
recognized which Ian Freeman testified
to protects the right to worship so I
also understand the clinical concerns
and I would recommend people to go to
maps.org that's the multi
multi-disciplinary Association for
psychedelic studies it's a 501c3
government funded they do a lot of PTSD
studies with all they're the ones doing
all this PTSD studies with the veterans
and drug addiction and stuff like that
um I'm actually trained as psychedelic
peer support specialist uh I would
suggest the gentleman putting forth the
bill to have all his staff trained as
psychedelic peer support Specialists as
well
um if they're not already
uh I he may have mentioned that I'm not
sure I came in a little bit late but
I think there's a two-pronged approach
here and if this bill was to make
all substances
you know
for religious purposes
because it's that would cover everything
the mushrooms and all these other
there's another one called ibogaine
comes from the plant iboga this is
specific to the opioid crisis and there
is a contra indication with this one as
well you got to be careful and make sure
you're not taking something that you're
not supposed to like an SSRI when it
comes to DMT but ibogaine is specific to
the opioid crisis people take a dose of
this they go uh into you know a six hour
they're in a closed room by themselves
they deal with all this trauma they come
out and they Nev it also kills any
withdraws if you're having withdraws but
withdraws immediately go away and then
they come out and sometimes in six
months they might do a revisit but most
people take one dose of this ibogaine
and it cures the opioid crisis I think
it was rep Murphy was wondering why
isn't this stuff being used well it is
being tested and it is being used
because they are seeing how powerful it
is the problem is Big Pharma
is all they want to do is push bills
that you have to take forever okay ever
since the Opium Wars every cure has been
a stronger opioid
okay they had opium then they created
Morphine Morphine became Hydromorphone
which is heroin and then it be you know
methadone and all these had Fentanyl and
it's just a stronger and stronger opiate
to cure the opioid crisis is not working
and we need to change that so
I think that
if this bill was passed it would also
expand the clinical usage and the
ability for clinicians to apply with
maps and
um you know people should have the right
to go through a clinician and get it
done but they should also and they do
have the right to go get it from his
church or whatever and yeah there are
dangers there are people who hold
rattlesnakes and they're allowed to do
that right there are people who die in
sweat lodges
okay so these things happen and that's
that's just that's a part of people's
spiritual spirituality and
um we have that right under the New
Hampshire uh Constitution Article Five
um
so let's let me make sure
yeah I do think that all drugs uh should
be exempt from any religious practices
or just really streamline that and fall
in line with the Supreme Court decision
uh there so
um
that said if anyone has any questions
I'm also in I do work in the uh the
recovery community on this local
coordinator for smart recovery I operate
Humble House LLC it's uh the only
uh alternative to the 12 steps
thank you uh representative Newell
hey Frank actually I think a memory just
came up you and I speaking uh on a panel
together about substance use disorders
yes right I've spoken on a few people
recognize me
um I was actually first going to say you
know it would be good to say that so
that people understand where you're
coming from I appreciate that and given
that I'm curious you know when you're
talking about ending withdrawals and
like its utility as a treatment in
substance use disorder is that
um is that well I guess first of all
is an opiate use disorder or all
substance use disorder that is good for
and then second of all is that anecdotal
or is there some type of reference to
there are studies I would suggest going
to maps.org and there are plenty of
studies there you can look at all the
different ones look up ibogaine opioids
if you Google it I'm sure there'll be
plenty of stuff that comes up uh it is
used for other things smoking and
alcohol as well but it particularly
stops the withdrawals of opioids and you
know people come out they've worked
through all this past trauma without a
therapist they've done it all in their
mind right like it's it's like a dream
world that you go into and you're not
you're not a danger to yourself
you can go and get these treatments I
know a guy a friend of mine he's got the
money took him five thousand dollars he
had to go to Mexico to get iboga
treatment he was doing like five grams
of heroin a day you know and he went and
he did this iBook of treatment and it
worked but most people and especially
the homeless people they can't do that
and you can easily you can get this
iboga in the ibogaine it's readily
available it comes from Plants we can
make it we can Mass produce it people
can produce it on their own and we can
really get to the heart of this issue
but again it's big Pharma and these
lobbyists who are keeping this stuff
from happening
it's all about billing Insurance even
the recovery Community these recovery
houses they send people into into
treatment then they come out I volunteer
I hope for New Hampshire I think I
mentioned smart recovery I asked them
what tools did they learn you were you
were in rehab for 30 days six months 90
days whatever it was they have they
weren't taught anything they go to these
me these little group meetings and
individual meetings and they're they get
build Insurance build Insurance build
insurance they get sent out put in and
then cycled back through
it's disgusting it's absolutely
disgusting and all the money's getting
funneled through this uh you know this
recovery Housing Coalition they got to
certify these houses so all the money
can get funneled to these houses that's
a conspiracy too and that's not okay
that's all you know one hand wash and
the other these people doing doing
favors for their friends and are we
going to solve the problem are we trying
to line everybody's pockets that's the
question
thank you
the chair recognizes uh Bonnie Freeman
hello my name is Bonnie Freeman and I am
a minister at the Shire Free Church as
well and I just think it's interesting
that Forest speakers including myself so
far have all been Ministers of some sort
I think it's interesting because I was
actually an atheist for a long time and
Minister holdren I'm not part of his
church or anything I was just talking to
him and he was I would consider it
ministering to me
um really helped me to realize that even
though I just I didn't believe anymore
in a god up in the sky judging
everything I did because I grew up
Christian then I broke away from that
um didn't mean that I hadn't seen any
evidence of God before and I just had to
think of him differently sort of
um I just wanted to put that out there
because I think it's interesting all of
us have had experiences with this
molecule DMT and it helped us it helped
open our eyes well I can speak for
myself in this part it helped open my
eyes to a loving
presence that's out there and also in
everyone
um
that I call God
so I just wanted to throw that I thought
that was interesting uh basically I take
DMT once in a while and uh the
government making it illegal in 1970 to
answer your question doesn't stop me all
it does is put me at risk for harm by
the hand of the government by utilizing
my natural rights to put into my body
whatever I want
but it's not going to stop me so the
laws against it are at the very least
that
um at the very least not effective
I've been diagnosed with PTSD and I work
with my dreams a lot and almost two
years after the incident that gave me
PSD I have dreams that I interpret as my
brain still trying to understand what
happens to me but during
um like a time that I took DMT
I've I mean I wouldn't say that it cured
me but it's helped me to change my
perspective on what's happened and even
look at the people who are persecuting
me in my church and my husband
with love like the people that I should
should want to hate like it's helped me
change my perspective
um and realize basically
um well I've only taken it uh in the
vaporized way I've never taken Ayahuasca
so that's a big distinction I've never
taken a six hour trip and I don't even
think I would have uh would describe
what has happened to me on DMT as the
furthest that you can go which like
people call it blasting off I don't
think that that's happened to me I
wanted to explain in just real terms
what it's like it's like
um you take it and you start to feel
really nice right away like you you
don't feel nervous I've told some other
ministers of mine that were thinking
about taking it and then did take it
because I recommended it as a sacrament
that with marijuana which a lot of
people are way more uh familiar with you
can easily just start to feel nervous
and you don't get that with DMT you just
it feels like somebody is there just
giving you like a
I don't know how to explain it except
for that you feel very relaxed and nice
you don't you don't get all crazy and
feel like you're out of your mind or
feel uncomfortable when you're taking in
the vaporized form I've never
experienced ayahuasca
um but basically you just start to think
of things differently and maybe you'll
see beautiful patterns um usually that
only happens to me when I close my eyes
so it's not like if I have my eyes open
I would be seeing a pattern but I know
people that that does happen to them
um
but things will look different and feel
different so in a dream a real dream
when you're sleeping you can kind of
know a thing and that will happen to you
while you're awake like my dog I have a
Chihuahua came up to me
and um while I'm just in the middle of
this and he comes up to me is just
looking at me right in the face
and I just knew that he was just saying
that he loved me it sounds kind of weird
but in a dream something like that could
happen and it's just like that it senses
that you don't have
in your regular waking state that you
have access to on DMT and I just want to
say that because I felt like a lot of
people were kind of talking about it in
a really
um around the subject kind of way just
wanted to explain exactly what it's like
it's not like being on marijuana where
everything is silly and you feel
paranoid and you your heart rate's
beating really hard you feel very
comfortable at the most I feel a little
heavy like
sitting down feels nice
and that's it that's all I wanted to say
thank you very much for sharing with us
today thank you
foreign
this time the chair recognizes Captain
Bill Boyd the New Hampshire State Police
thank you very much committee for
hearing my testimony my name is Bill
bright I'm a captain with the New
Hampshire State Police
and this bill as it's proposed to
legalize DMT
um
Our concern is obviously with the public
safety of
the citizens of the State of New
Hampshire with the it's classified as a
hallucinogenic drug as it has been
testified to this is also a schedule one
drug uh which makes it illegal federally
um
Our concern would be that with it more
readily available to the public there
would be more widespread use which would
lead to more impaired drivers more
access to children and not necessarily
for the people who who are taking it but
for the others that may be affected uh
as a result of their use of this drug so
for those reasons we would oppose the
bill as it is written
representative Peru
so to the fact of people driving is
there a test to determine if this is in
their system how much is in their system
and are they Under the Influence why
they're driving uh it would be just
regular impairment that an officer would
be able to detect
um but as far as a test to determine uh
this drug other than a drug recognition
expert doing an evaluation I'm not a
drug recognition expert so I can't
testify to what those indicators would
be that would help them determine what
type of drug a person is on but other
than that no there's no test that I know
of
representative selling
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony I'm I'm curious if the law as
written were amended to say that it was
to be
um
removed from the controlled Drug Act
explicitly in for clinical or religious
settings would that
make any difference to the perspective
I'm just wondering like
perspective wise if it's used in in like
a set safe Zone type of thing does that
change the nature as with any Amendment
or any Bill we would have to take a look
at the at the wording and and make a
judgment call at that time so I'm I'm
not sure how to respond uh to that
Captain if you could tell us are you
aware um is this readily available now I
mean is it is there a black market for
it currently available
this is nothing that I've come across uh
in my career to my knowledge it's not I
it's not seen often obviously there's
been testimony that it is available in
um in different forms but it is not
something that I've come across uh
personally and I don't know of any uh
current current cases thank you
representative wheeler
thank you Mr chairman thank you Captain
bright
um
how many people are pulled over per year
if you could follow up with this number
if you don't know it off the top of your
head
um in regards to who are high on
hallucinogens I'm not aware of those
statistics I can look into that uh for
you if you if you would like
anecdotally would you say a lot of
follow-up Mr chairman sorry still
getting used to this
um anecdotally would you say that there
are a lot of people who are pulled over
who are on a hallucinogenic substance
um well as you know I mean an officer
won't be able to determine that at the
time that they pull somebody over they
would be looking for impairment
um that the numbers I I'm not aware of I
I don't know how many people are pulled
over for hallucinogenics I can look into
that for you though
foreign
I think your objection as I hear it is
the same as your objection to marijuana
it's what the effects of driving is it
not I don't see any other issues that
you've raised well there could be there
could be many other
um effects as far as it's my
understanding that a person who uh is
under impairment of this drug
specifically that it's unpredictable
High I guess so to speak like no I I
don't believe that anybody knows how
it's going to affect them ahead of time
um or or how long or anything like that
so A person who is under the influence
of say this drug for an extended period
of time may come across many different
situations and in an altered state of
mind we would be concerned about the
safety for them and for other
individuals that they come in contact
with while they're under the influence
of this drug or of any drug
or because I don't know
thank you Mr chairman
um could you speak to uh you know I
guess the implications of it being of
course federally it's a schedule it's
you schedule one drug
um if it were legalized um as written
uh in the state what would be the
implications of it being federally
illegal and legal in the state a person
would still be subject to the federal
penalties if they were charged federally
for uh possession can I follow up
okay so you're here on behalf of the
State Police right so State Police you
know that's under State jurisdiction so
if it were a federal law enforcement
that would be
um dealt with federally and um that's
correct or if if the federal if the
federal law was was broken they could be
charged in in a federal court
thank you Captain thank you
is there anyone else wishing to testify
on this bill who has not done so
ah
I was just uh Derek informed me he has
additional testimony to clear a few
things up and I just ask his Kersey he's
the expert that I asked to be here for
this
um so I think his testimony would be
extremely valuable he would allow that
um actually I I'm late for my next bill
so I will not allow that but I would
welcome him to email us with and if he
wanted to rebut what he heard uh
generally we don't take for a bottle
testimony so I'd be happy to um you can
email the whole committee and we would
take a look at it
thank you thank you
at this time I'm closing public hearing
and I'm going to open the public hearing
on HP 144fn
and recognize
our rep Gerard
um that guy was the one who made me
drawing
foreign
thank you chairman
members of the committee here again my
name is Jason Gerhard representing
Northfield Franklin
and here to speak on
restoring firearm ownership rights to
ex-felons
non-violent ex-felons emphasizing the
non-violent part
I had testimony submitted from
several people unfortunately I did not
bring printed copies for you I would
like to submit emails afterwards I'll
forward them I just want to address one
right real quick it's very short
where
this is a resident of Manchester
which as you know is
not high crime but not definitely not
low crime so she's a single mother two
children
and she writes my name is Molly May
Washington retired army combat veteran
currently a registered nurse at the
Veterans Administration in 2015 I served
at three air state prison sentence for
non-violent Financial crime embezzlement
restitution will be paid the remainder
of my life I own a home in Manchester
New Hampshire and have 13 year old twins
it is not safe I contacted I contacted a
lawyer Penny Dean in an attempt to
restore my rights a year ago
current law prevents my second amendment
rights from being restored so long as I
owe restitution
I am off parole and have satisfied my
sentence police revised the law to allow
non-violent felon Second Amendment
restoration upon completion of their
sentence we shouldn't have to pay a
lawyer six thousand dollars to
accomplish a constitutional right
it was unknown to me until very recently
there's actually a cottage industry in
New Hampshire
where we have attorneys that help people
get their gun rights back through the
annulment process and so forth
so there's obviously some opposition to
this bill on that ground which I can
understand but point being is
if someone is done with their sentence
and they qualify on the annulment
situation we already have on in state
law I see no reason why we should have
to file a bunch of paperwork expend a
lot of money in order to defend
ourselves and our families we already
have the Second Amendment right oh sorry
not Second Amendment New Hampshire but
we have the right to bear arms protect
ourselves and our property and so I'm
ex-filing myself non-violent
I served 12 and a half years
I'm about to be done with probation here
in a little bit a couple weeks and I
just it's hard for me to understand how
we can have a state representative this
is my situation obviously but we can
have a state representative who cannot
defend himself so if I'm going out into
the parking garage late at night
and somebody else you know hates sweet
cheeks I'm just you know I'm just joking
around but if somebody is there's no way
for me to defend myself I mean I have a
knife but come on and it just it just
doesn't make any sense to me especially
now also we have women and that's
another thing with single mothers and I
I don't know it's just so hard for me to
explain everything in the sense of the
absurdity of it all if you're done with
your sentence and you're non-violent you
have no predispositions of violence it
what are we doing really all we're doing
is funneling people into the court
system with the pay obscene amounts of
money in order to regain a right that
they were born with
um the last point
that I want to make
uh
get a little tripped up here in my mind
okay we got some counter action uh
I would just I just think that it's
important to recognize everybody's life
as equal and I just don't see why we
should say that you have the ability to
defend yourself and you don't especially
when these people have shown no no
violence towards anyone else I just I
don't know I'm just confused about this
whole thing so any questions I'd
appreciate it I did have more to say but
I'm getting tripped up now so I'd
appreciate it thank you
thank you um what is your understanding
of the
we have these two two tiers the the
federal
prohibition on felons possessing
firearms versus the state in other words
if you if you were you're asking for us
to take care of the state portion of it
and you're understanding with that would
that get rid of the federal part too
no I'm as far as I'm concerned the
state's sovereign
as other people and I
I'll deal with the federal part of this
let's put it that way I'll I have
another bill in to deal with any gun
made within the confines of Mont uh I
keep saying Montana that's where the law
originated in 2008 any gun made within
the confines of the State of New
Hampshire is not subject to Federal
jurisdiction the interstate commerce
clause has been extended to Encompass
everything the whole game is concentrate
power in DC which I think is really
detrimental to everybody in the state
especially considering article 7 State
sovereignty but
hopefully that answers the question it
does thank you
thank you in my mind
violent crime and drugs go together and
I don't think I could find myself
supporting this if unless you we amended
it to include uh non-violent or to
considered drugs as a violent crime
uh if you're talking about embezzlement
I don't the objection to that but do you
have any how do you feel about uh the
include
considering drugs as a violent crime and
by the way your probation lasts two
years okay got elected for two
oh oh you're saying stay yeah I was like
hold on no
um as far as drugs go I think we'd be
Crossing into a very dangerous territory
so let's go back to my whole little
prison stint
um
what are we going to do with alcoholics
what are you going to do with people
huffing paint propane I didn't even know
people have propane I found out when I
was campaigning in Franklin somebody
told me somebody exploded down the
street years ago on it but we have
there's just so many there's so many
addictions that
to just try to say okay these illegal
drugs like we just heard on DMT we just
heard that so if somebody gets caught
with DMT we're going to take their right
to defend themselves and their families
away from them now you can say well they
could be violent there's a lot of things
that could happen you're a man you could
be violent in the right circumstances I
think we need to judge people by what
they have done not what they could do or
might happen in the future it's just you
don't try to get at it just gets very
dangerous for instance marijuana is
considered the most dangerous thing ever
and now recently look at Colorado
everybody just kind of gave it up on
except for New Hampshire but they just
kind of realized the writing on the wall
and just kind of accepted what it is I
know if that's answering a question
exactly but I just don't want to delve
into that territory because it just
seems like a tomorrow if marijuana is
legalized what are we going to do now
restore all that gun rights it just
thank you uh representative thank you
for your testimony thank you very much
um this point the chair calls
representative Jr hole
hello chairman members of the committee
uh representative Jr hole um dunbart New
Hampshire
um former member of Edna so my good
friend up here representative scitex
going to understand what I'm about to
make as an argument
we do have a lot of non-violent felonies
if you pull up the chapter on
occupational licensure
shows up about 90 times
landscape architect doing forestry I'll
pick on the field that I'm in
engineering
okay if I do engineering and I do it
under an end a DBA it's no longer a
natural person it falls under right a
doing business as which means it's
another entity which means instead of a
misdemeanor level offense it's a class B
felony
restoring the rights of citizens who
haven't hurt somebody okay is an
important thing and I'm here as a as a
board member of New Hampshire Firearms
coalition to talk about long term we've
misused the term felony in a lot of our
statutes this may be a Band-Aid to start
fixing that the correct thing would be
to write use felony for violent level
offenses
we don't we use it for a lot of things
an occupational licensure is the one
place and I can send the committee the
list of places it shows up between
section 308 and 322 there's a lot of
them
um as a penalty
citizens should not be denied their
natural and constitutional rights
because
of archaic and complicated laws and
something as simple as a failure to pay
a hundred dollar licensing fee
right if prosecuted rarely does that
happen but if prosecuted could put you
in jail so with that I'll close my
testimony
thank you representative thank you
the chair recognizes Mr Frank Staples
thank you again Deja Vu you can see I am
I am armed I am an ex-felon
um and I believe that
I am not a felon anymore because of New
Hampshire RSA 607a
that is the uniform act on the status of
convicted persons Okay so
whether or not my crime my felony was
violent or or not
once my sentence is over
the state statute automatically gives me
back
My Three core civil rights my right to
vote
serve on a jury and hold public office
the federal firearm statute
this is a frequently litigated issue
this comes from 1435 post-conviction
restoration of civil rights this is
federal a frequently litigated issue
under 922 G1 is whether a convicted
felon is exempt from the prohibition
prohibitions of the statute because of a
post-conviction restoration of civil
rights under state law in accordance
with 18 USC
921 921a20 which gives an exemption if a
conviction a conviction does not
disqualify an individual from possessing
firearms if the person convicted has had
civil rights restored
in 922 G1 cases based upon State felony
conviction courts have uniformly looked
to the law of the state where the
conviction was obtained to determine
whether the defendant's civil rights
have been restored and whether sucks
such action has nullified the
convictions incidental prohibition on
firearms possession with respect to
felony convictions the Supreme Court
declared impeachment versus United
States that only federal law can nullify
the effect of the conviction through
expungement pardon or restoration of
civil rights this is so the Court ruled
even though there is no federal
procedure for restoring the civil rights
of federal felons okay so it's different
for federal felons
in the United States versus Ramos the
Court held that the term restored
requires the state to make an
individualized official judgment that
the defendant should be
accepted from the provisions of 922 G1
the Criminal Division takes the position
that where the state law contains any
provision purporting to restore civil
rights which 607a does either upon
application by the defendant or
automatically upon completion of
sentence it does automatically in New
Hampshire it should be given effect it
is not necessary that the State issue an
individualized certificate reflecting
the Judgment of State officials
regarding an individual defendant the
Ramos case should be limited to
its unique facts and not extended to
attempts to nullify the effect of other
state schemes for civil restoration
estate restoration document that is
absolute on its face should disqualify
the affected state felon from
prosecution under 922 G1 the federal
statute so if if it's going to preclude
them from prosecution so I'll be
precluded from prosecution for holding a
firearm under 922g
then how can the state
convict me for being a felon in
possession if the feds are relying on
this state statute to determine that I'm
not a felon so I posit that the
certificate of discharge 607 A5
gives us back all our civil rights we
suffer no civil death upon completion of
our sentence once we have no restitution
we're not we're not serving probation or
parole which I'm not I'm completely off
paper so it's my understanding in my
interpretation of the law that I can
currently I'm not considered a felon the
problem is
this 607a it defines what a felon is but
it doesn't explicitly state it nowhere
in the state law is felon defined felony
is defined sure a felony is defined and
violent felonies are defined in
non-violent you can't turn non-violent
things into violent I mean that's pretty
crazy that this guy's even suggesting
something like that
um I will say that that's absolutely
ridiculous and you should you should
resign sir you want to keep testifying
yes then keep it so whether it's violent
or non-violent once someone served their
conviction
then they're no longer considered a
felon but so I would I would say that
607a backs up that chapter backs up this
bill the um and it just needs to be
clarified that in in the annulment
statute needs to be repealed there's no
need for an annulment process and
statute have to pay for the lawyers
because
607a already gives us back our rights
but it's very very
um sophisticated language that you have
to decipher to to uh to get gather all
this
I can read
um
right here the certificate of discharge
if the sentence was imposed in this
state uh the other instrument blah blah
blah completion of uh after completion
of service of his sentence or after
service of probation or parole shall
state that the defendant's right to vote
and hold any future public office of
which he was deprived by this chapter
are thereby restored and that he suffers
no other disability by virtue of his
conviction and sentence except as
otherwise provided by this chapter and
nowhere in this chapter does it say that
you're not allowed to have a firearm in
fact
the right to bear arms
which supersedes the Federal
Constitution this is the New Hampshire
Constitution all persons have the right
to keep and bear arms and defense of
themselves their families the property
and the state so I would like to be able
to carry a gun I carry knives all the
time and I've defended myself with a
knife legally I've never assaulted
anyone and I would like to like rep
Gerhard be able to have a gun in case I
need to stop a mass shooter which has
been done in in certain places there are
a lot of crazy people out there and it's
right here it's protected in in the
State Constitution and RSA 607a so I
figure maybe I'll go out and buy a gun
today
thank you for your testimony thank you
any questions
no he has one
I have a question to the chair we've
just heard an explosion of rsas I don't
know what he's talking about can we get
an opinion from the attorney general
whether he's making sense
oh I'm making absolutely RSA 607 I'd
love it would that be public sir
would I be able to get a copy of that if
he pulls I would love that from the
attorney general yes yeah yeah anything
they produce love his interpretation on
RSA 607a I've already tried to get it
thank you
I don't know attorney Steven endres
please
good afternoon my name is Steven
Anderson I'm an attorney with the
Merrimack County Attorney's Office I've
been in a prosecutor for a little over
20 years
with reference to
um
guns it's sort of always a hot button
issue and people have very emotional
responses either way but
the the fact of the matter is no matter
how you feel about guns the way it is in
New Hampshire in
is you have a right to bear guns and
Firearms unless there's a specific
legislative act that prohibits it
the current statute
RSA 159 3 is exactly one of those
statutes it sets forth a category of
people
in that category of people are people
that have been convicted of felons
against the person or property of
another
or drug felonies and it sets forth a
penalty
which make it a class B felony for those
individuals to possess firearms
when I look at this bill one of the
things that strikes me
is the first part of it repeals RSA 159
3.
so it would repeal that category of
persons as well as the prohibition
making a class B felony
and it replaces it by saying
uh
people convicted of felonies that did
not involve committing an act of
violence to have the right to possess
firearms
with reference to felonies that did not
involve an act of violence it makes me
wonder what that means I hear the term
non-violent felons but
I would assume that for a felony to
involved an act of violence it would
actually have to have an act of violence
as an element of that felony
and the build defines act of violence as
physical harm inflicted upon another
individual
there's actually not a lot of felonies
that have an element of physical harm
inflicted upon another individual
for example burglary is a property crime
there's no element of violence in
burglary
um
arson is a property crime there's no
element of violence in arson kidnapping
and stalking don't have any elements of
violence within their their crime so I
guess those would be considered
non-violent felonies as well
um aggravated felonious sexual assault
doesn't have an element of physical harm
um in it either
so
all
all of those things don't have an
element which requires a person to be
injured
statutes that require a person to be
injured for example the murder statutes
first degree assault second-degree
assault
the only drug statute that I can think
of that has an element of physical harm
is the death resulting statute
but essentially all of those statutes
where there isn't an element of physical
harm wouldn't come under the language in
this this amendment
the other thing that I notice when I
look at this in section one is there's
no penalty provision
so
as I read it it says
non if you're convicted of a felony that
didn't involve committing an act of
violence you have the right to possess
and use a firearm
but what if you're convicted of a felony
that did have an element of violence
it wouldn't be a class B felony anymore
because we would have repealed 159.3
so it would essentially open it to
all felons whether you are convicted of
a violent felony or not
I also think it's odd that the statute
itself says that you have a right to
possess and use firearms as I had
indicated earlier essentially everyone
has a right to possess Firearms unless
there's a legislative act that restricts
you from doing so we don't need laws
that specifically say this group of
people has a right to possess firearms
and I think writing a law that says this
specific group has the right to possess
Firearms becomes confusing because
there's other laws that restrict the use
and possession of firearms
for example you can't discharge a
firearm within 300 feet of a permanently
occupied dwelling
that goes for everybody
but if you're a convicted felon and you
have the right to possess and use a
firearm
does that law apply to you now or does
this law Trump the one that says you
can't fire within 300 feet of an
occupied dwelling
it also
for example in New Hampshire if you're
the subject of a protective order you're
restricted from possessing firearms
if there's a lot that says specifically
that a certain group has a right to
possess firearms
and if there's another law that says if
in fact there's a protective order
issued against you you don't have the
right to possess Firearms which law wins
in that case
it's also worth noting as indicated
earlier federal law still prohibits
um people convicted of felonies of
possessing firearms
so even if we were to get rid of 159 3
it would be a federal felony to sell
somebody a firearm if they were a
convicted felon and it would be a
federal felony to possess a firearm if
you were a convicted felon so it's not
like you could go to your local gun
store and legally purchase a firearm
even if this bill were to pass
looking at the second section of
House Bill 144 it talks about armed
career criminals and again this suffers
from sort of the same difficulty it says
in offense that involves an act of
violence or threat of violence and then
defines that as bodily injury or the
imminent fear of bodily injury but again
I presume that would have to be an
element of the crime there's very
limited crimes that actually have that
as an element
there's a number of enumerated felonies
in the second section one of which is
arson but again arson doesn't have an
element of bodily injury or imminent
imminent bodily injury arson is a
property crime
so it makes you wonder
how many arsons could you have before
you became an armed career criminal and
frankly I I think you could have as many
as you wanted because there's never an
element of violence in an arson case
same thing with burglary
there's no physical harm or threat in a
burglary it's it's the crime of breaking
into someone's property with an intent
to commit a crime within that property
so theoretically you could have as many
burglaries as you wanted and still
possess firearms
same thing with robbery
there's there's a version of robbery
that does have bodily injury but
generally
um
robbery is not a crime with that element
child sexual abuse images there's no
element of violence in in that crime
and then looking at the third section of
the bill House Bill 144 it amends
the exceptions provision in 159.5
which currently says 159 3 and 159 Ford
to just bring it to RSA 159.4
so law enforcement would be exempt from
RSA 159 4 which
makes no sense at all to me because RSA
159 4 was actually repealed in 2017.
so it would reference a statute that no
longer exists and say that this group is
exempt from this statute that doesn't
exist
so
I think there's
certainly the philosophy of allowing
felons to have guns which I would not be
in agreement with but if you did adopt
that philosophy the language in this
bill certainly in my opinion doesn't get
you there
so that's why I'd ask that you find it
inexpedient to legislate thank you
representative scitec
you're the Merrimack County attorney
right I am an assistant County attorney
in Merrimack County I may proceed yes
are you representing other there is nine
other counties uh are you do you have
are you claiming to represent them or is
this your own offices or your own
opinion where is this coming from where
are you coming from so I only represent
the Merrimack County Attorney's Office
as I indicated earlier I'm an assistant
County attorney in Merrimack County I
have spoken with attorney Halverson who
is the Merrimack County attorney he
couldn't be here today but he and I
um did discuss this bill at length and
we agree on the the shortcomings within
it
representative Pro
so
in your opinion
kidnapping is a non-violent crime
in my opinion kidnapping does not have
an element which requires bodily injury
or an imminent threat so I'm just gonna
go with you
you can certainly read the kidnapping
statute I think representative that he's
talking about the the specific language
in this bill versus those specifications
I mean I can expand on that each crime
has Elements which the state has to
prove Beyond A Reasonable Doubt so for
example
um
you know burglary we would have to prove
that the person entered the dwelling of
another at night with the purpose to
commit a crime they're in
um
none of those elements require bodily
injury or the imminent use of physical
Force
so
when we look at whether or not something
is a a violent felony I believe as this
bill defines it
it says a felony that did not involve a
committing an act of violence and an act
of violence is defined as physical harm
inflicted upon another individual
so the only way you would know if that
crime had an act of violence and if the
jury found or essentially the finder
effect finder found an act of violence
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt would be if
that act of violence were an element of
the offense
and as I said earlier burglary doesn't
have an act of violence as an element of
the offense I don't believe kidnapping
has an act of violence as an element of
the offense
so you could certainly have a very
violent kidnapping
but it doesn't have an element of the
offense
involving an act of violence
so in my opinion the only way you could
have a felony that involves an act of
violence is it would have to be an
element otherwise you'd have to go back
and look at the the alleged facts of
each individual crime and decide
essentially on a case-by-case basis
whether or not it was a a violent crime
or not
and and I'm not sure how you would
possibly do that
I won't even go to arson thank you
I was going to go there yeah
representative Pratt
I believe Austin is charged in two
different levels if you chat if you have
a set somebody's house on fire at night
when they could be sleeping there I
believe they charge at a higher level
and then if you set a fire to somebody's
house in the daytime
it's a lower level of crime because it's
assumed that people won't be sleeping in
the daytime and at night time they are
so isn't that a felony
of crime a crime of
of injury or possible injury
you mentioned Austin wasn't I did
mention arson it's funny you think arson
would be in the index but it never is
um
so arson is
a property crime
arson is 634-1 it says a person's guilty
of arson if he knowingly starts a fire
or causes an explosion which unlawfully
damages the property of another
so there's no act of violence or threat
of violence in arson
arson's class a felony if the property
damaged is an occupied structure and the
actor knew it was occupied or a historic
structure so again there's no element of
violence or threat of violence in that
are
but it
again violence is defined as physical
injury to a person okay I won't believe
with the point
um
thank you thank you
thank you for your testimony today
okay now
that chair recognizes Dr Hannon
better thank you
um good afternoon my name is Joseph
Hannon I'm the vice president for gun
owners of New Hampshire and I'm speaking
in favor of the bill
um there's a just for a little
background uh under federal law
convicted felons lose the right to
firearms and this decision stems from a
1934 law before that time for over 150
years in this country if you did the
time did the crime did the time your
rights were all restored they handed
your gun back if they took it before you
went to jail no matter what the crime
was if it was so severe that you
shouldn't be out on the streets you
weren't usually released
so it wasn't even a problem or even a
consideration from the founding of our
country and the writing the Constitution
until 1934. in 1968 the gun control act
uh changed it to anyone convicted of a
felony whether or not it involves
violence loses their right to Firearms
there's also Provisions as you've heard
to have rights restored at the federal
level and also they can be done at the
state level through different mechanisms
depending on the state but we also know
that the federal level has really no
implementation of following through on
that mechanism at the federal level
that's that's funded or if you try to
find the phone number to call to have
your rights restored I still have not
found that phone number
um
the federal prohibition on non-violent
criminals is not supported by the
original understanding of the Second
Amendment this is a new phenomenon since
1968. uh there are courses and there are
cases in court uh currently there's one
out of Philadelphia there was one in
Colorado uh that people are trying to
get the rights back for non-violent
crimes uh I know I believe that I can't
remember the name of the case offhand
but the Philadelphia case they're
relying on the recent Supreme Court
decision over the summer that people
have a right to to bear arms but
um
this is uh one of the biggest
um I guess rebuttals to that is well you
know reasonable regulation all this all
these different examples of why you can
have laws against everyone having a
firearm but uh what we don't hear about
is the uh we do we should hear more of
is the Supreme Court also said that it
should be based on the original intent
and that was the purpose of the last
several big gun rights cases we've uh
that have been decided on by the Supreme
Court and the intent was obviously not
to restrict the rights of non-violent
people from bearing arms
um even our own uh state constitution
says
on penalties uh article 18 I'm sure
you're aware of penalties to be
proportioned to the offenses true design
of punishment
all penalties to be proportioned to the
nature of the offense no wise
legislature will fix the same punishment
to the crimes of theft foraging the like
which they do to those of murder and
treason
where the same undistinguishing severity
is exert against all offenses the people
are led to forget the real distinction
of the crimes themselves and to commit
the most flagrant as with little
compunction as they do the slightest the
latest offenses
so you know is the a non-violent crime
of writing a bad check 30 years ago or
you know uh food stamp fraud
you know 10 20 years ago is that
something that's worth depriving someone
the right to defend their lives and the
lives of their loved ones I don't
believe it is I think that is definitely
not proportioned to the crime and have a
blanket
um law that says you can't have your
rights that are inherent rights uh I
think is absolutely wrong uh and real I
don't want to go too long because I said
I would only be a couple minutes but um
you know a few little things about the
bill as far as specifics
um there is an except it says it
shouldn't apply to U.S Marshals
sheriff's police or other law
enforcement officers bailiffs Court
officers Etc so we're creating a special
class of citizens again it's already in
the law a lot of these laws don't apply
to uh to those people but if you have an
officer who is allowed to keep their job
or a military person who was convicted
of a felony inducted into the service
they're serving their time they could be
walking around with a rifle and active
duty in New Hampshire and that's totally
legal uh so we've created little second
classes we've created different classes
of citizens and how they're to be
treated in New Hampshire with Firearms
laws uh and there was a comment made
about uh
you know violent drug laws you know and
and I asked myself if someone is
someone who's purchased or used or tries
to sell the drug
um ethanol is that person a violent
Criminal
if they are I think we have a lot of uh
questions to ask our own state for
selling it on street corners all
throughout the state so just by the
inherent fact that someone is using a
drug sold it or possessed it the only
distinction is listed versus illicit
drugs and that is something that is
being debated in other bills and laws
around the country and from personal
experience I can tell you I've never
been assaulted by someone who was on
cannabis and this is not a cannabis bill
but I've never been assaulted by someone
who was on cannabis in a bar it's
usually someone drunk gets beer muscles
and they get all into full themselves so
I don't think we should draw those
distinctions on our uh our own perceived
biases towards different substances
because I'm not going to ask it for a
show of hands but you know if if you
raise your hand if you drank alcohol you
may be a violent criminal so I'm happy
to take any questions
what is the position of the organization
on um we were talking about felonies but
isn't it also true that any misdemeanor
where you could spend up to a year in
prison it triggers a federal buyer to
possession of firearms uh we'd be very
happy for an amendment to extend it to
all those also I'm
if someone is not convicted of violence
or someone is not a violent person why
should that right be
taken away and in this state it is not
decided necessarily in a case-by-case
basis if you've been convicted you are
automatically denied that right beyond
the terms of your punishment and debt to
society
you know we always heard I heard growing
up you pay you do the crime do the time
but also you paid your debt to society
when does that happen apparently death
is when it happens
so just to follow up
an oui conviction a what an oh uh
driving Under the Influence conviction
you can lose your right to carry
firearms because of the potential
penalty absolutely is that accurate yeah
thank you representative Newman
I just have a quiet follow-up to your
question what about a DUI or oui
conviction that caused injuries is that
a violent felony and that gets to is
there a good definition either in local
I mean New Hampshire or federal law of
that uh I think it is addressed in the
language of the the bill in this
paragraph and active violence means
attempting to cause or purposefully or
recklessly causing bodily injury or
serious bodily injury with or without a
deadly weapon
so I believe that would be covered if
someone is uh seriously injured I
whether I agree with or not I don't want
to say because I don't know the
specifics of any individual case but if
someone is injured by this I would read
it as they they would be prohibited and
not exempt under this bill
thank you I think that covers if this
bill becomes law that would be the
definition then
thank you thank you
uh chair calls Ian Freeman
thank you for uh for listening here I do
support this bill although I don't think
it goes far enough
uh the fact is there's the reality and
then there's what the law says
and the reality is if a violent person
gets out of prison after being convicted
for a violent crime and that violent
person wants to go and get themselves a
gun
it doesn't matter what the law says
they're going to be able to get a gun
where there's a will there's a way and
if they want to go and commit another
violent act they're going to do that
they don't care what the law says by
definition that kind of person doesn't
care
about what the law says they've proven
that by the fact they violated it in the
first place so really what these
prohibitions on felons owning guns or
possessing guns prohibits is the people
who've tried to turn their lives around
the people who maybe they did something
wrong when they were in their teens or
their 20s and then they spent some time
in prison and then they got a family
together and they started their own
business or you know whatever the story
is they've turned their lives around
they haven't uh recidivized they haven't
committed another act they are now a
valuable member of society but they're
prohibited because of a mistake they
made in their past from being able to
protect their families and themselves
and the New Hampshire Constitution is
very clear when it says that all persons
have the right to keep and bear arms in
defense of themselves or families their
property in the state it doesn't say
with the exception of if the legislature
doesn't like them
so like I said I support the bill but I
think that quote-unquote violent felons
do not all go on to commit more violence
and they should also be included in this
legislation
because they're humans too thank you
and I don't see any questions thank you
Mr
anyone else wishing to testify who has
not testified on a spill
seeing none I closed the public hearing
what's next
what does it do right now I think this
crowd is here for the blackjacks okay
and this time I'll open the public
hearing on HP 31 and recognize
representative spleen to introduces bill
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee thank you for uh allowing me
to introduce this bill I am
representative James Spillane
representing Deerfield
Candia and Auburn
uh
based on what I've heard I hope this
one's a lot simpler than what you've
been going through
HB 31 is looking to repeal two rsas RSA
15916 and one RSA 15917 which Trails
once uh colon 16 and is tied to it
um
RSA 15916 prohibits people from owning
or selling uh
blackjacks slung shots and metallic
Knuckles brass knuckles
there's no reason
to have a Prohibition on these items
anymore we allowed knives of any length
to be legal in New Hampshire over 12
years ago we have uh
uh people able to carry firearms for
self-defense and the truth is that
blackjacks slung shots and brass
knuckles are purely non-lethal defense
weapons
tools to be used to protect yourself and
quite frequently um let me Define what a
slung shot is because most people don't
know what it is it's essentially just a
weighted stone or or a ball on the end
of a braided rope
and quite often uh those are sold as
monkey fists and they're carried on
keychains
uh quite often women will carry these to
be able to offer some form of
self-defense if they're assaulted when
they're walking alone
uh Blackjack is the same sort of thing
except that it's a leather strap with a
weight in one end
and
um
these
strictly non-lethal
antiquated
methods of self-defense should not be
prohibited from an option for somebody
in addition to being able to carry a
knife or pepper spray or what have you
[Music]
um
if I go to the the actual statute
because it wasn't included in the bill
and I think that it's it's important to
also hear how it's it's written
15916 says that whoever except as
provided by the laws of this state sells
has in his possession with intent to
sell or carries on his person any
Blackjack slung shot or metallic
Knuckles shall be guilty of a
misdemeanor and as such and such weapon
or articles so carried by him shall be
confiscated to the use of the state
what the state's going to use it for I
have no idea but the state can go around
collecting them confiscating them and
then using them
the reason I've also asked to repeal
colon 17 is because 17 basically says
the provisions of the preceding section
all of 16
shall not apply to officers of the law
to persons holding hunting or fishing
licenses when lawfully engaged in
hunting or fishing
which is how I became aware of this as
the chairman of Fish and Game to
employees of Express companies while on
duty to Watchmen while on duty to
emergency medical technicians
firefighters military personnel while in
the course of their duties or a duly
authorized military or Civic
organizations when parading or to the
members thereof
goes on there's a whole lot of people
that are allowed to carry this and and
exempt it from the previous section
but it's such a poorly written bill
that when they put this exception in it
accepted the entire first paragraph
which also included selling so you've
essentially said that all of these
people listed here can sell
blackjacks
slung shots and brass knuckles so police
officers could open little boutiques in
the back trunk of the car and sell brass
knuckles slung shots and and uh
blackjacks out of the back of the trunk
of their car a hunter in his tree stand
could open up a briefcase and open up a
little shop and sell them perfectly
legal because this is so poorly written
that the second paragraph exempts the
entire first paragraph for this group of
people
and it's it's just a shambles
so I'm asking you to repeal both of them
they are widely in use in the state
they're not being this prohibition is
not enforced except maybe as a secondary
offense if they stop somebody for some
other offense and they say oh we can
also add on another charge because
they're carrying that
one more thing I'll add before I finish
and take questions
you can go through the airport and TSA
will not take a monkey fist off your
keychain or a blackjack off your
keychain if you're carrying one
it's not considered a lethal weapon and
they don't care if you carry it on a
plane
if TSA is not going to prevent us from
carrying those on a plane why are we
saying that you can't carry them around
to Via self-defense when you're walking
to a dark parking garage in the middle
of the night
thank you
representative scitec when you read that
list of PR at the original Bill original
Law you said possession with intent to
sell is it possible to just outright own
it no it says whoever except is provided
by the laws of the state sells has in
his possession with intent to sell or
carries on his person what
what prohibits just outright ownership
in that carries on his person
technically I suppose you could own it
in your house and frequently we've seen
I mean growing up I've been in New
Hampshire all my life and you could go
down to the local uh five and ten shop
and you'd see brass knuckles for sale
and they would say they're paperweights
it's and right now you can go onto
Amazon and buy a blackjack
and it's called a a book weight
because it's a leather strap that has a
weight on the end that holds your book
open but it's a blackjack
and a monkey fist is just a steel Bell
bearing inside a braided paracord that's
hung on your keychain and it's
considered technically a slung shot
but it offers somebody just like
wrapping your keychain up and having a
key ready in case you get assaulted it
offers you something easy at hand while
you're walking to your car that you can
use to defend yourself so you can run
away it's a non-lethal tool
thank you thank you
uh the chair recognizes representative
Hall
thank you chairman representative hold
Dunbarton here on behalf of the New
Hampshire Firearms coalition
the New Hampshire Firearms Coalition is
a 501c4 non-profit representing the gun
owners in the state and all those this
bill has almost nothing to do with the
gun owners directly it has to do with
something called possessionary offenses
and in this case its possessionary
offenses of self-defense tools from the
early 1900s
right today people would carry mace with
them or pepper spray that would be the
vote most common non-lethal tool that
someone would carry with them if they
wanted to protect themselves
that has supplanted most of the ones on
this list
um these are now collector's items let's
call them what they are these these are
things that go in museums for the most
part
um so because it's a possessionary
offense and possessionary offenses it's
it's not what the tool is it's how the
tool is used murder is a crime because
you've used something what baseball bat
acts firearm doesn't matter whatever and
you've harmed someone that's a crime we
we definitely have laws that prohibit
crimes and we we do things about crimes
but the mere possession of something
should never be an offense unless it's
part of a criminal right part of the
evidence of a criminal activity right I
have a stolen good that's a different
story
so we would ask that you would pass this
because we leave these laws on our books
that really aren't enforced that um as
the as the prior member said right he
wants to buy a paperweight to hold his
book open
and it just happens to be sold to
something else they do sell knives that
happen to have a series of finger holds
built into the hilt that
potentially under and overzealous
prosecutor could be prosecuted for one
of these laws type thing and all it is
is a better way to hold on to the to the
knife
so with that I would ask the New
Hampshire Firearms Coalition as an
organization supports this supports the
repeal because these this law is is
Antiquated and it really has to do with
effectively collectors item self-defense
tools thank you
thank you
the chair recognizes Frank Staples
I live in a horrible neighborhood in
Manchester New Hampshire and as I showed
you earlier I have a knife a knife is
actually more deadly than a gun if I was
to stab somebody with this it's over
with I would prefer not to have to do
that and be able to use something like a
club a blackjack a sap or some metallic
Knuckles Not only would it keep me from
likely killing this person and causing
you know the ambulance and all that
but it would protect my hands as well so
anyone who has to use their hands for a
living whether it's typing or doing any
work that would allow people to protect
their hands if they ever did have to
defend themselves in a situation like
this and I mean it's absurd I'm allowed
to have a sword on my hip and and all
these knives but at any length but I
can't have a a little blackjack or or a
monkey fist or something like that it's
it's pretty crazy and like uh J.R Hull
said there's already crimes if you
assault somebody with a pen it's a salt
with a deadly weapon if you assault
somebody with a rock it's all if you saw
somebody with a sap a blackjack
unprovoked it's not self-defense then it
is assault unprovoked assault so we
already have crimes and I think of being
redundant at this point thank you
thank you no questions
I'm sorry representative Newman
yes uh Mr Staples
Mr Staples I think
um I'm not sure if you just said it or
the previous uh representative
but I I just kind of quick looked while
there was testimony going on brass
knuckles could be carried on and could
get through TSA but they would have to
be in a checked in a checked bag check
thing and I think there have been
instances when TSA has confiscated
whatever you want to call them a brass
monkey thing or whatever sure check bags
do I have a question
yes do you agree with what I just said
um
I mean I know that they they sell on
eBay they sell like bulk things that
have been confiscated by TSA that people
never came back to claim so I'm sure
there's probably I've never purchased a
thing like that but uh I'm sure they
confiscate things and make mistakes like
these I think we the problem that we
have here is there are just too many
redundant laws that aren't really doing
anything except causing a lot of
confusion you know we have these assault
laws somebody assault somebody's assault
whether it's with a weapon or without a
weapon and the weapon could be anything
could be this Clorox thing like
all right thank you
Dr Hannon
hello again oh it's on good
um johannan from Gunners New Hampshire
um like representative hole said
um I'm from a gun organ gun uh
organization in New Hampshire but uh
this is relevant because it has to do
with any kind of uh arm or um possession
case
um I actually had to look up some of the
terms I know obviously I know what brass
knuckles are
um I know what a blackjack is but a
slung shot I just wasn't sure exactly so
I looked it up and I was like oh yeah I
know what that is
um but historically it was uh it was
actually used for maritime reasons
um
it was a way to fix a way to fix to a
long chord to be used to cast a line
from one location to another which
explains why in the current statute it's
except it's one of the exceptions to
carry any of these items during hunting
or fishing if you have a valid license
and you're doing that activity so um
it's okay to have it I guess if you're
doing that but it's I don't really see a
way how you can buy it or sell it unless
you happen to see someone else hunting
or fishing and happens to have a
blackjacks you know or whatever the
brass knuckles with them or slug shot
and you can buy it while you're both
hunting and fishing or they're a law
enforcement officer or any other one of
these other uh exceptions
so um
I I do believe that a lot of these
things are are not even going to be
really used at all for even self-defense
purposes as there are far better ways of
doing it
um you don't even need a permit to carry
a firearm in New Hampshire if you're
legally allowed to obtain a firearm
um that's a pretty you know uh
Superior method of self-defense but not
everyone can afford hundreds of dollars
for a firearm so if someone is poor this
is actually something that disadvantages
people they can't afford four or five
hundred dollars just to defend
themselves
um the law also talks about and I'm sure
this is you know just semantic but uh
you know has in his or her his
possession with intent to sell
um it I guess women are allowed to have
these things doesn't say anything about
her it just says his so I don't know
maybe just I'm reading too much into it
but interestingly enough it says if
someone's convicted or someone has these
items it's a misdemeanor but if any such
weapon or articles is carried by him not
hers it shall be confiscated to the use
of the state so I guess the state really
needs brass knuckles slug shots and
monkey fists of or you know all these
items because you know this is how we're
going to get them so I don't think this
is a really uh important law to keep on
our books I think it's uh superficial
and actually a silly law to keep
considering all the other laws that we
currently have
thank you
representative Gerhard okay
thank you chairman members of committee
make this super fast representative
Gerhard Northfield Franklin I just want
to support this bill and to address what
you said earlier about TSA and brass
knuckles I know that people you can have
belt buckles with brass knuckles on them
so I'm pretty sure that would get best
if you wanted
so and just curiosity say did anyone
file opposition to this bill
just curious all right thank you very
much
anyone else wishing to testify and this
bill was not testified
there's being none uh here I close the
public hearing